there's no time
13 o clock
[Music]
hey you guys episode 172 going back to
the true-crime on this one and what I've
started doing is because we've had so
many different like requests and
recommendations for different serial
killers different murder cases stuff
like that so on the list that I have of
upcoming episodes and ideas for shows
and stuff I've started like arranging
all of them and sort of like loose
themes you know what I mean like either
by country or by city or by similarity
of the crimes or whatever so I decided
on this one since I had had so many
requests for different Canadian serial
killers and we have done a couple of
other shows about some Canadian crimes
like we did one about all the crimes in
Toronto and stuff like that so I thought
I would just throw like four different
cases together on this one and just call
it a Canadian crime extravaganza I guess
a couple of serial killers and then a
couple of other just kind of horrific
crimes that are not necessarily
constitute serial killers but we'll get
into that bit so we're gonna be talking
about David Russell Williams we're gonna
be talking about Luca man yata Bruce
McArthur probably one of the
longest-running serial killers who might
have actually been responsible for way
more than they suspect and I also want
to talk about at the end I want to talk
about the murder of Tim McLean because
someone requested that a while back and
I remember that [ __ ] happening because
that was a [ __ ] horrifying that was
the one on the Greyhound bus you know
where somebody just kind of murdered a
guy that was sleeping and cut his head
off and started eating him it stops I
don't agree huh yeah why was driving
no I think it was parked I don't know no
maybe it was driving actually I'm not
really sure yeah but it's like it was a
case that I remembered it was from
several years ago but it's kind of hard
to forget so yes somebody requested it a
while back so I'm finally getting around
to doing that so that'll be what we're
looking into on this episode but before
that like we usually do let's do a
couple of shout outs got a bunch of
people to shout out this week we've got
two new patrons this week I'm
Matt and Heather so hi you guys thank
you very much thanks for Ward and I
would also like to give a shout out to
Gwendolyn for a PayPal donation so thank
you very much for that now look at this
[ __ ] you guys I just got this in the
mail today we're recording this on a
Saturday yes you remember on our show
last I guess it was loud the
Thanksgiving show we were talking about
like the grocery store Piggly Wiggly
okay well one of our listeners Eric who
lives in Milwaukee sent us this amazing
awesome Piggly Wiggly boob a shopping
bag and look the best part is that their
website y'all is shop the pigs around
shop the pig doesn't sound like a
grocery store website but yes thank you
very much but I laugh my ass off when I
open that kitchen we just got it like
literally a couple of minutes before we
started recording this so you know yeah
other than that I think probably the
only starting my jackets falling down
behind me um the only other things that
I have to shout out or just the regular
[ __ ] I usually shout out go check out my
audio book The Associated villanies on
my fiction I'm still working on hopeful
monsters it's just taken longer than
usual as it normally does also faceless
villain 3 whoever is leaving like
reviews and stuff like that thank you
very much that really does help a lot if
you like the books leave a review yeah
it really does help when it more whose
have the better they sell yeah cuz you
know like I said it's the same kind of
thing I don't really like to buy
something sight unseen if I don't write
yeah but not that I listen to other
people's opinions all that much but you
know alright so let's start talking
about some of these [ __ ] I was
actually going to do another Canadian
crime on this one Evelyn dick somebody
asked me to do her she's not a serial
killer she just allegedly killed her
husband and cut him up and probably also
killed her kid but I think I will save
her for maybe like a female killer show
cuz you know what I mean so I'll
probably do that because I already had
four and I was like I don't want this
to be like three hours long you know
what I mean because I got [ __ ] I gotta
do so I decided to just go with these
four because these are kind of like big
sort of famous cases so the first guy
we're gonna talk about is David Russell
Williams now this guy this was like a
huge deal because this guy was kind of
on the surface he seemed like he was
like a really high ranking like military
after he was a colonel um you know he
had like he was a pilot and he was like
a VIP pilot he had like flown the
[ __ ] Queen of England and the Prime
Minister and all this other kind of [ __ ]
and as it turns out he was also a rapist
and a murderer
so you know that's nice when you find
out that kind of [ __ ] he actually was
just arrested in 2010 so these are
fairly recent cases most of these so
Colonel Russell Williams
I guess he usually drops the first name
because I've seen David Russell Williams
and also just Russell Williams so I
guess he just went by his middle names
or whatever he was 46 years old in 2009
and he actually became the commanding
officer of eight wing CFB Trenton which
I so he was like the head of like this
[ __ ] Air Base or whatever it was yes
so he was like the boss you know what I
mean um he was actually originally from
the UK but he had moved to Canada with
his family when he was a kid so he had
had like a really good education he went
to like University of Toronto all this
other kind of [ __ ] now he joined
actually the Canadian military forces in
1987 and just kept like you know going
up in rank and as I said you know he had
flown around like very important people
and [ __ ] like that he had all kind of
medals he had all kinds of like he did a
tour in the Middle East yeah yeah and
like I said he was like kind of like an
elite he ran like the whole [ __ ] base
and everything like that he also had a
wife her name was Mary Elizabeth
Harriman they'd been married for 13
years and they had a house in a suburb
of Ottawa and then later moved to
another one like in the capital now like
I said on the surface it would seem that
he was just like this really normal dude
I mean he was like really educated he
was like high up in the military like no
one suspected a thing
evidently however one thing that he
would do I guess him and his wife owned
this cottage in this little village
called Tweed Ontario which was 33 miles
from where they normally lived or where
the base was where he worked he decided
I guess that he was just gonna start
breaking into people's houses like
around this cottage right and I don't
know how long he'd been doing this
because you know he only admitted to so
many and you know they ended up catching
him later on but I'm thinking he did
like a lot of these and then it like
steadily got worse
she's an Air Force colonel and a pilot
and successful but he's gonna break into
people's cottages yeah this is unusual
yeah so this is the kind of [ __ ] this
was almost kind of like it's like a BTK
situation but BTK was like not all that
successful and I think he kind of wish
that he would whereas this guy was like
very high-ranking like I said and he you
know we had a wife they didn't have any
kids or anything but it's like you know
I mean he seemed like a totally normal
dude so the first crime of his that they
know about happened on the night of
September 8th now he broke into a
neighbor's cottage like I guess this was
like their vacation cottage or something
like that this wasn't their main house
but this was like you know a place that
they went for vacation so the family was
not there but he broke in and took a
bunch of like I guess they had a younger
younger and he would like take all her
underwear like out of the drawer and
like put it on like I said like BTK and
take pictures of himself like in
pornographic poses he also stole some of
the underwear yeah and like captive
right imagine this dude's your [ __ ]
commanding officer jizz
what is it that that's what kills me
it's like can you imagine like finding
out about this like I mean it's bad
enough like his wife finding out about
it but this is just like all the people
that yeah that he was like the
commander's romantic idea holy crap can
use a chart imagine and he's like
totally he looks totally like he is
right from military guy central
casting you know I mean like if you saw
a movie in the 80s like Top Gun or some
[ __ ] like that and he looks exactly like
you would expect like he's got like that
big square jaw and like that put that
face like that and you know what I mean
and it's like he looks just like that
and to imagine him and there's picture
there's pictures on the internet too of
him like in various lingerie and like
pictures of himself and stuff but it
seriously it gets worse so this is like
how it started out apparently just in
his mid-40s I guess he decided that he
was gonna go around and start breaking
into people's houses at first when no
one was home stealing underwear taking
pictures himself in the house with the
underwear now I don't believe it
you don't believe it no I've seen the
picture probably no I'm saying believe
it just started in his forties I don't
think so either
I said the back he was like I suspect
that there was a lot of this kind of
[ __ ] going along on along comes back to
when he was like 10 or 11 uh-huh yeah so
so there was a bunch of these types of
crimes he started breaking into other
houses like I said at first when no one
was home and then in May 2008 there was
another rash of this type of crimes like
near his other half like not his
vacation cottage but the house that
where he lived with his wife now what he
would do like I said at first no one was
home he would just break in and like
take pictures and take underwear and
stuff like that so some of the early
[ __ ] was not reported because no one
realized that anyone had broken in like
they didn't notice anything was missing
cuz it's like you know if they somebody
just took a pair of panties or something
like that you would just think oh I lost
him in the laundry or something like
that you wouldn't think that some weirdo
had broken in and like taking your
panties you know the mean is that I mean
I would think that but most people
wouldn't think that because you know I
don't know this [ __ ] goes so yeah he
would um he would either come in through
an unlocked door he would cut a screen
open he would force a window open or
pick a lock he would so he would spread
the the panties and [ __ ] like out on the
beds or and he would like take some of
the other words now apparently he had 82
of these that's how many he admitted
that he had broken into 82 houses and
done this kind of [ __ ] that's a lot of
work yeah that's what I mean it's like
when the [ __ ] did he have time to do
this kind of stuff
I don't know were all in that area they
were again like around the vacation
house entrance like all of the houses
around as the occasion is that's like
all of them problem like I said I guess
the only reason he got away with it for
so long was because a lot of people
didn't notice like they didn't report it
and they're there they weren't there
because you know he was going on the off
season
I suppose so or he would just like watch
them and like wait til they were out
because I'm assuming these were all like
neighbors or people in the same
neighborhoods where he lived that's
weird he wasn't really stealing anything
big just paying just panties and stuff
that's why sometimes it wasn't reported
that's why they only knew later on like
when they caught him and like they found
all his photos and video and [ __ ] like
that you know what I mean sit cuz some
people didn't notice and like if
somebody just cut a screen open and
crawl that you wouldn't necessarily
notice that if it was like an
out-of-the-way place now he later
admitted that he had stolen over 1,400
pieces of lingerie from really healthy
housing all this in bags and stuff they
finally said they found it later yeah so
like I said you know initially all of
these were very minor and they didn't
get reported but however there were a
few houses that um in the suburb where
he lived um I think that he did like 25
break-ins in that area now 15 of those
people did report it because they did
notice right um so they staked out like
the undercover officers like staked out
the whole neighborhood but they didn't
see anything unusual so at this stage
they consult a criminal profile with the
Ontario Provincial Police and he said
and he turned out to be right about this
I guess that's why he's a criminal
profiler is whoever did this if he
doesn't get caught soon
it's gonna escalate like he could tell
like from the way that the break-ins
were done he said this guy is gonna get
bolder and bolder and eventually it's
gonna get bad so you should probably
kind of pull out all the stops and try
to find this dude because yeah it
doesn't seem like a
now somebody stole my panties but it's
like this looks like something that's
gonna get worse and like I said he was
right about that because in some of the
later crimes he started doing [ __ ] like
like he would leave a message on the
computer like he would type something in
there like in one house he was in the
room of a 12 year old girl and he left a
message on the computer that said merci
like thank you and he stole her panties
so he was a little bit of a pedophile -
yeah and also in another house they
found like a photo of a woman and there
was semen on it
so so the profiler was like yeah this
dude is like gearing up for rape so
let's kind of like try to find this do
you I've got a feeling that's been going
on though he was started all that [ __ ]
probably stealing his mom's or his
[ __ ] I don't wonder about that like
some of this peeping tom on the
neighbors and then maybe he goes off the
service eventually or you know goes off
to school then it cost he can't do it
there for a while but then you know when
he got into the military and got him to
a certain you know level of power he
went back to his old ways it was
something like that
yeah because this is something I mean
like I said it was somewhere had he not
gone into the military was started it a
lot earlier yeah it was something like
that because he was doing other things
in his professional career yeah I mean
like nothing is impossible but it's very
very unusual for a serial offender like
this to just start doing this kind of
crap in their mid-40s that's very very
strange yeah I don't believe it and you
know and and we're gonna get into it a
little bit more when we talk about Bruce
MacArthur - because by the time they
caught that [ __ ] he was like in
his 60s so and he did some of the
murders from his 60s but they suspect
although they can't prove it that he
might have done some [ __ ] back in the
70s when he was in his 20s and I kind of
believe that because you got a look at
this stuff kind of like this is a sexual
orientation yeah you know I mean you
know you don't have your first sex
experience of 40 not unless there's
something wrong yeah it's gone down much
earlier than that
it's just this is just this is just he's
what they're describing here is his
latest spree before he got caught yeah I
bet you there were other sprees that was
different than this they went on for a
long time in everything get god that's
kind of I suspect try stuff like peeping
tom yeah stuff like that cuz like I said
it would have been had to have been
something where it was probably largely
not reported or was not taken seriously
like you said peeping tom kind of [ __ ]
or like the [ __ ] he was doing at the
beginning just breaking into people's
houses and taking their underwear
sneaking around putting cameras up
people's skirts us in the store you know
upskirting people yeah yeah like that
that type of [ __ ] right [ __ ] where you
wouldn't necessarily notice it or like I
said even if somebody reported it they
wouldn't really take it all that
seriously yeah there's something like
that but see that's why they that's why
they should take this [ __ ] seriously
what items that [ __ ] as legs off on a
thing when he'd do that for three or
four years then he changes MO and do
something else keep getting bored yeah
this is just one this is this is the
latest one that he got caught on yeah
that this led up to something that's I
think that's I think happen I yeah I I
agree with you on that so just as the
criminal profiler had predicted to women
in the suburb of tweed were attacked in
September of 2009 the first victim they
did not release her name she did not
want to release as she just goes by Jane
Doe that was on September 17th and a
woman named Laurie Massicotte on the
30th now both of these women were asleep
in their apartments and Williams broke
in tied them up blindfolded them
sexually assaulted them and forced them
to pose naked for pictures so both of
these victims then like I said this
these attacks happened only like a
couple weeks apart obviously both these
women reported this [ __ ] to the police
but the police did not warn the public
about it until after the second one you
know what I mean he must have my was one
of those Polaroid cameras that develops
the film on its own was all ones because
how could you how could you take that
anywhere to have it developed well this
is in the 2000 so yeah my been digital
camera yeah because he had a but when
they
they caught him they had like he had
like a [ __ ] ton of photos in his head
yeah these are digital photos I was
thinking is go back in the nineties yeah
so the police like I said they they kind
of warned the public about it they at
first called this guy the tweed creeper
and started going door-to-door like
looking for information about him
unfortunately they could not find
anything now only a few months later on
November 23rd 2009 there was a town
called Brighton which is just west of
Trenton where his airbase was Williams
broke into the house of a woman named
corporal marie-france Comeau now she was
actually under his command at the base
as Annette so yeah he broke into her
house and you know started like
struggling with her she like fought back
against him he hit her on the head with
a flashlight and knocked her out um he
repeatedly raped her over the next two
hours when she started fighting back he
started beating the [ __ ] out of her she
didn't recognize him um I don't know
because she died okay I'm sure I'm sure
she did wonder if he tracked her down he
knew who she was like Oh Aram I would
assumed that he knew she was yeah
sauron basis is I'm gonna get that one
yeah I'm assuming I don't know if he was
wearing a mask or anything really
um so yeah he he actually recorded
himself doing all this on video and
photographs photographs yeah um then he
covered her face with duct tape and
asphyxiated her damn then he wrapped her
body up in a like a comforter and left
her in the bedroom and took off
damn he's our coordinate with this video
game mm-hmm was there his phone or
whatever yeah so they didn't find her
until the following day like when people
noticed she was missing or whatever so
they you know they they searched her
house and everything like that and the
creepy thing is that after they had
discovered her dead the Colonel Williams
who was her commanding officer he sent
like condolences to her dad Dan yeah
can you Matt like [ __ ] cold
the hearted [ __ ] god damn it what
the [ __ ] is the matter was evil yeah
now the next victim was named Jessica
Lloyd now he broke into her house near
Belleville Ontario very early on the
morning of January 29th she was sleeping
he again he raped her made her pose
naked for photographs then he dragged
her out to his he had a silver 2001
Nissan Pathfinder that was like parked
in a field near her house so he dragged
her out there threw her in the car drove
her to his cottage continued to rape her
for several more hours then cracked her
skull open with a flashlight and
strangled her with rope okay now the
first one what what date was this one
year 2009 November 2009 and this was
January and then the sec 2010 this is
January 2010 so a year no a few months
you might say what would you say it was
November November and then end of
November 2009 and then the next one was
January so there's only like two months
later all right
but supposedly that first voices was his
first one that's what he's client
claiming that's the first murder first
murder not that I don't believe it not
the first rape see I don't believe that
either I don't believe that either I'm
blue yeah so believe that was the first
one no I don't think I said this does
not start 40-something years old yes the
first one
and then a couple months later does does
murder number two so he you know he
cooled off in a two-month period there
were other guys that would do one and
then it took him a couple years to get
to get the balls to do it again yeah you
know I mean and then it started to
accelerate so I just don't believe it
this is this is habitual
this is this is habitual I think yeah I
mean this kind of behavior isn't on
again off of yeah and like I said this
is something that we'll probably get
into when I'm talking about Bruce
McArthur too because I think that
[ __ ] like I said allegedly cuz I
can't prove it they don't have like
evidence or anything like that but
nobody just starts being a serial killer
in their [ __ ] 60s no I mean that's
I'm not saying it's impossible but super
ugly that is very very unlikely
so I kind of think that probably this
guy and that other guy had done some
[ __ ] they usually [ __ ] didn't usually
start in their teens yeah like I said um
I was watching the thing the other day
Michael Arndt field who wrote the book
about Toronto that I used for our
Toronto show he said the peak age for
serial killers or for murderers in
general in the United States at least
was 31 that was like the most common you
know what I mean so with all the
averages of things what was that what's
the what's the average age for when they
start though um that I don't know I'm
saying that's we yeah it's probably
early teens well because and we've
talked about a lot of them on the show
it's like usually you know that they're
gonna go bad by the time they're in
their teens because they don't even if
they don't start murdering people they
start doing other types of criminal
behaviors and fires [ __ ] yeah animals
like I said doing peeping tom type [ __ ]
you know that kind of stuff yeah lots of
stealing yeah
Breaking and Entering all it's just like
this guy did so I kind of feel like and
again you know just like Bruce MacArthur
nobody starts being a serial killer in
their sixties nobody starts being a
serial killer in their [ __ ] mid 40s
mid to late 40s this guy was so yeah
especially not after a successful career
that [ __ ] happened first and then he
became and then he yeah maybe he was
even trying to like fix himself or cure
or something I don't really I think it
was an on-again off-again thing yeah
maybe it just like came over him you see
I think he started it young and then
quit and then went back to it and then
quit and they went back to it yeah but
you're through for me episodes of this
yeah that seems very likely because year
with years breaks in between that's just
what I cuz there have been that some of
them that were like that yeah and this
guy this guy seems like one of those
well like I said it's kind of like dije
because he did all those and then -
Purina made him stop for like several
years that's why I didn't I mean the
only reason they [ __ ] caught him is
because he's like oh but he's forgetting
about me able to start sudden [ __ ]
matters it was he was like that yeah so
just like in the first case all the
horrible things that he did to Jessica
Lloyd he also recorded that on video
for a while he hid her body in his
garage or the garage of his cottage and
then a couple days later he went and
dumped her in the woods near tweed which
is like
you know suburb now obviously Jessica
Lloyd didn't show up for work and was
reported missing because her car was
there but she wasn't home and like you
know her friends and family got worried
so they the police pretty quickly
figured out that this missing person
which is what she was at the time was
very likely linked to the other sexual
assaults that had happened in tweed
where the women survived and also the
other murder of the of Miss Comeau so
they they start this massive search
ironically the search included personnel
and a search and rescue aircraft from
the base where Colonel Williams worked
and he was the one that theater eyes the
use of the personnel and the aircraft
yeah he's getting on in the search he's
getting off on all this power because
they're asking him to search for the
killer oh yeah yeah yeah
so didn't ever invite him so they have
all these cops they have all these
volunteers but they don't find her for
like a week but they did have a bunch of
witnesses that said that they had seen a
silver SUV parked in a field near her
house on the night she disappeared
so the cops went to the field and they
found very distinctive tire tracks and
they knew that the tire tracks were
probably from a Nissan Pathfinder or a
similar vehicle like they narrowed it
way down so the cops set up like um like
a road like a checkpoint and they said
they were looking for drunk drivers but
that's not what they were doing
so Colonel Williams actually got stopped
at the checkpoint so the cops start
asking him questions about Jessica Lloyd
and then they start looking at his tires
Carl Wims is like hey can you hurry this
up my kid is sick at home now he doesn't
have any kids right but they didn't know
that at the time they found that out
later
however the cops were still suspicious
because his tire treads looked very much
like the ones that they had just
recovered from the field near Jessica
it's house so they couldn't arrest him
just on that but they did put him under
surveillance because they thought it was
very suspicious um later on when they
found out that he didn't have any
children and had lied to them about hey
can you hurry up I have a sick kid at
home so they decided well we're gonna
ask him to come down here so we can like
ask him a few questions about something
else you know what I mean
so they actually got him to come down
there like willingly because he thought
they were gonna ask him about some other
[ __ ] I guess so once they get Colonel
Williams in the interrogation room
the detective is just like um hey so we
heard you were hanging out in that field
by Jessica Lloyd Tessa started like
peppering him with questions about her
disappearance and they also noticed that
the boots he had on were the same ones
like they matched the footprints that
they had found like in the field like
near where the truck had been seen there
was like outside of her house in the
snow vidcon yeah so what they did to is
while he was in the interrogation room a
search party had been sent out to his
house and his wife was like what the
[ __ ] and she was like super surprised
but I guess she let them in and like let
them look around because she didn't know
what the [ __ ] was going on so they start
searching the house and then like the
search party would like relay
information back to the guy that's
interrogating him just like hey we found
this hey we found that like ask him
about that you know what I mean so they
had it all like hooked up and [ __ ] so
the more that they kept asked him and
asked him to ask him it and finally he
just couldn't like tonight anymore so
the detective is finally finally like
okay so what'd you do with her like
where is she Jessica Lloyd because they
hadn't found her yet at this time
and finally Colonel Williams fesses up
and he says well give me a map yeah tell
you one thing or where the body you sure
know where the body was you can do the
Canadian [ __ ] military's embarrass us
hell I'll tell you that having this
[ __ ] it's the [ __ ] base commander
but at least they had some decent law
enforcement yeah you can tell the
difference between modern law
enforcement techniques and how efficient
it is and say like what we had back the
70s and the 80s how [ __ ] up they were
yeah that was it and everything was like
written on pay
keeper and no communicated with each
other and yes letters written on index
cards in a box and I don't know where
the [ __ ] they really didn't know how to
profile them and you know what I mean
they wouldn't they would put certain
people above suspicion when there is you
can't put anybody above suspicion you
know yeah that's one thing I can say
about that law enforcement they seem
pretty [ __ ] on the ball they got on
it I mean they linked the sexual
assaults they linked them to the murders
pretty much right away they you know
they set up the thing they got the tire
tracks so they caught him like pretty
quickly had this happened didn't say the
us back in the 7/3 from Canada back in
the 70s he had gotten away for kind of
wait for a love well a lot of people did
lager like I said it's like you know
they didn't have like now it's like you
know shit's immediate and everybody's
like you know on the internet and they
can track your [ __ ] cell phone and
everything like that they're gonna say
oh yeah that you know those murders were
his first ones because he raped what
three three girls total before he
started on it before he killed the third
victim but that that's not necessarily
true either there-there's serial killers
that have let victims go before could
have been he was trying to get back into
it he just kind of warmed up to it after
a while yeah you know I mean but I don't
think those are his first I don't think
so I suspect there's some other shake I
think he did some I think maybe he did
someone he was younger yeah and he
missed it yeah and then like after a
while he's like a while he went back to
it so they searched his house and his
cottage and everything like that they
did like a massive search of all his
stuff they found his camera they found a
duffel bag containing like a black like
a skullcap which maybe he like pulled
that over his face partially he had a
lock-picking manual he had a whole bunch
of boxes and pillowcases that were
stuffed with stolen underwear and
lingerie in the ceiling of the basement
of the house in Ottawa they found two
computer hard drives which had like kind
of encrypted files but they were able to
like encrypt them they found he had he
had caps like meticulous records of all
his activities as a sexual predator like
in over two years
he had video clips
three thousand pictures including
several of the women that he murdered
the woman that he raped [ __ ] like that
he also kept like a detailed log of all
the break-ins that he had done and like
the underwear that he had stolen he had
it was like an inventory of all the [ __ ]
hmm so he was like [ __ ] this is Jake
he's just like BTK he's like one of
those really weird like super anal
retentive it's like and I stole likes
you know yeah 36b bra yeah lace red what
the [ __ ] it's like that is so crazy
yeah so yeah so obviously more important
things to do holy [ __ ]
so yeah they found all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
in there like well guess he's guilty
holy crap it's like gee thanks man for
doing all our work for us that was nice
of you so yeah so they arrest him and so
obviously everyone is shocked his wife
is shocked the [ __ ] military is
shocked because no one suspected
anything like about this dude so he gets
taken to court in Belleville on February
8th and this was a 2010 I guess yeah he
gets charged with murder sexual assault
forcible confinement because he had tied
you know many of the women up he was
also charged with many many counts of
breaking and entering now he spent eight
months in a place called the Quint
detention center and kind of made court
appearances I guess they did like Skype
or whatever he actually pleaded guilty
to all the charges so they never did put
him on trial however over Easter weekend
April 2010 he tried to commit suicide by
cramming a cardboard toilet paper tube
down his throat
unfortunately they rescued him yeah yeah
so they put him under a suicide watch
and as I said since he had Pleet pled
guilty at least they actually sentenced
him to two life sentences that's fine
with no possibility of parole for 25
years also he had to register as a sex
offender they destroyed all of his the
underwear and [ __ ] he had stolen and
they destroyed his Nissan Pathfinder why
are they worried about registering him
as a sex offender he didn't get life he
did yeah what are they worried about
that for were they gonna release him
it almost seems like they do it like for
a shame thing so like now if anybody
likes searches name not only will
murderer come up it's like oh you're
also on the sexual offender registry
did you know you hear about that that
stabbing on a London Bridge that just
happened like two days ago uh-huh
yeah I had a guy yelling you know Aloha
snackbar and he'd like stabbed like four
people and one of the guys that jumped
on him and pacified him turned out to be
a dude that slit his girlfriend's throat
and killed her he was serving a life
sentence he was on day release huh
London is so [ __ ] up that they're
releasing the murderers to stop the damn
[ __ ] knife terrorists huh imagine s
[ __ ] that's pretty crazy that's some
weird [ __ ]
yep they were calling him a hero he's
serving a life sentence they had never
mind there are no here yeah for a life
sentence for [ __ ] slitting his
girlfriend's throat although hey he did
save some people true but like I said I
don't think they're gonna give him a
life is complicated I don't think
they're gonna give him early release for
that though no I doubt it cuz yeah but I
don't think the British public knew that
the murderers with life sentences were
walking around walking around on day
release huh
yeah does it yes that's pretty hardcore
yeah that's crazy yeah go ahead come on
back before dark man that would never
happen here that would never happen here
yes so um so on the first day of his
guilty plea like when he was in court or
whatever he actually did admit to like
details from a bunch of other sexual
assaults that they didn't know about he
also he admitted to one where he had
broken into a house there was like a
woman in there who had just had a baby
and she let him like the baby was asleep
and he had like raped her I guess and
beat her over the head or whatever so
they hadn't found out about that one so
now they know about that also found out
like I said earlier that he had
of a pedophile thing going on that some
of the underwear that he had stolen for
was from girls as young as nine years
old he didn't discriminate
I guess not knows if it was female he
wanted that underwear yeah so he
actually ended up admitting I mean not
only to the rapes and murders but also
to 82 home invasions and attempted
break-ins between September 2007 and
November of 2009 so like I said he you
know he had taken thousands of pictures
he had like an inventory of all the [ __ ]
he stole it's like there were pictures
of him laying on the beds of like his
victims and like jerking off like
wearing their bras and underwear and
[ __ ] like that like I said there's
pictures of him all over the internet
like in that in the lingerie so weird
Amanda so that's that's like really
that's really close to him and BTK
that's what yeah it made me think of
that it seems like the same type of dude
and that's making me think that this was
these were not his first murders no
ATK's first murder was you know that
little girl and that family yeah number
her yep and then he went for what
decades before he killed it was a while
yeah and this dude's that same way yeah
it's that it was [ __ ] like that he did
something a long time ago but he's not
gonna fess up to that because he
probably has some kind of hopes where
he'll get out yeah that's what I think
yeah living in a fantasy land I mean he
like I said about two life sentences
they said oh well maybe he'd be eligible
for parole in 25 years but I'm sure he
will not get it and he will be like in
his 70s by then and then he may he may
also like have some appeals to yeah you
know you might be appealing for lighter
sentencing and [ __ ] like that so he's
not gonna he's not gonna confess yeah
two prior murders yes that's right yeah
because you know what I mean it a [ __ ]
up what he's got what he's got right now
I guarantee you yeah what he's got right
now yeah well he thinks he can he
probably when these dudes about that's
only 25 years I can do I've got six
years served already got saying and now
actually what ten years he's getting
he's got a got a got ten years served
all right he's like 15 years yeah yeah
yeah we're talking like week yeah yeah
where's Dennis what
Denis have to say about this you gotta
feed me good 15 years
no biggie yeah look at this little it's
like you can just see the foot dad proud
there you go get his little like that
guys all stand oh you know I don't know
you know 15 years yeah this seems like
he'd be a friend ears well you know I
can understand it me there's a man a man
of my taste you know yeah that's what I
was thinking I could have been a Carl
uh-huh yeah so yeah not surprisingly the
Canadian military was not happy no they
gave him they expelled him from the
forces for service misconduct which is
the most serious charge they can do they
also burned his uniform yeah cut up all
his medals yeah
shredded his commission scroll yeah and
and crushed and scrapped his vehicle
yeah his [ __ ] on fire because they were
just like I said they were not having it
they were just like trying to [ __ ]
destroy at the [ __ ] jet that Chuck
Connors remember that Chuck Connors
series called branded yeah yeah yeah
they put it through that they look at
Brandon Brandon Brandon his ass as a
coward and kicked his ass out yeah yeah
like I said it was falsely accused that
was quite a good series I'm an old
cowboy series yeah pretty much all I
remember is the theme song part the
thing it had been better had it been
directed by Sergio Leone but it was you
know that's Travis found a little bit of
a clean-cut cowboy flake in to a certain
extent no one's dirty yeah well just you
know it looks a little too much like
guns
you know like Gunsmoke yeah so
apparently yeah yeah yeah okay I did to
kind of like my grandparents used to
watch it
um so apparently this douchebags wife
Mary Elizabeth Herman knew nothing about
his extracurricular activities let's
call it that
obviously not surprisingly she also
divorced his dumb ass he's actually in a
maximum
purity prison at the moment however I
believe that he is still collecting a
military pension while in prison and he
also still had access to because I guess
like him and his wife like jointly owned
like all their properties and I guess
like after the divorce was finalized
they like split them up so apparently he
still owns one of the houses like I
think she got one of the houses and he
got one of the houses but it's not like
he can go anywhere and like go to Vegas
on spend it on hookers and blow or
anything like that he's in a [ __ ]
prison so here we're gonna see you
ladies day no I knew that you know
rightly so I don't think he should but
yeah so um yeah as I said I probably
won't put any in the video well maybe I
will just for shits and giggles but it
wasn't kind of putting videos of all the
pictures of him with like various
underwear on but it's like most of them
I mean the ones that I saw I mean I'm
sure there's like worse ones out there
but the ones that I just saw that came
up like in articles about him and stuff
he was mostly just like standing like
you know hey it's nice or whatever it's
like he was you know so there were
apparently like a bunch of kind of more
pornographic ones where he was laying
there jerkin it or whatever and like
ladies underwear it's like I don't I
don't understand that man yeah I could
feel that yeah yeah I'm sure you can all
right I've been there been there yes you
have I told you it's you know everybody
does it of course that everybody okay is
that what you think that is everybody
does it okay all right so yeah all right
so that was the the first case of
Colonel David Russell Williams douche
bag number one down now let's talk about
douche bag number two looka man yata now
you when I said his name you or when you
saw the picture of him you you see you
recognizes it this is not a serial
killer but oh [ __ ] yeah this is so crazy
male porn star so haters eating his
Chinese boyfriend yeah well wasn't his
boyfriend it was just some guy I thought
they were dating they were seeing I
don't think they were
no okay yeah I think I know that's not
how the that's not how the media is
perforated at the time that there was
something going on between the two I
don't know if there was but I didn't
have anything that was having sex with
him an ATM all this a live stream it was
kind of like that it was it was the
video wasn't a live star wasn't okay
yeah but he released that video to the
Internet Betty that showed up on [ __ ]
4chan it was unrealistic or best course
gore calm yeah which I don't know if it
any just gotten this dude man I saw him
suffocating those puppies inside those
Ziploc bags or kittens in a ziplock bag
I saw that video of him doing that and I
was just going like I'm gonna cut that
dude's head off this guy actually I just
read that December 18th which is only
like a couple weeks from now I think
Netflix is putting out a documentary
that's about this case and about like
how the internet like kind of comes
conspired to like catch this guy and
it's called don't [ __ ] with cats yeah
don't [ __ ] with them kids yeah that's
what the name of the thing is he was
trying to he was trying to make
suffocate and those kids look real cute
and everything he said yeah I like it's
like like like it's like it's like it's
a gay sexual experience or something
this dude's nice you know and I was just
like this dude needs a Mexican face peel
yeah at the very least yeah Connor
fought slobs out there he's listening to
me he knows of the Mexican face peel is
he sent me some photos of this [ __ ] you
know that is it yeah well actually he
didn't send me pictures today he sent me
a pictures of some dudes setting another
dude on fire that was my video
what's a Mexican face babe thank you I
mean next to me I can imagine you run up
on a dude and knock him out BAM and when
he's knocked out you and your team
[ __ ] coming up on him you cut his
hands off and then you take you know you
scalp somebody yeah
instead of scalping the times you Scout
the face circuit and when I was on two
they can't figure out what's wrong with
the Faceman
they got no hands and [ __ ] and it's
[ __ ] evil hell raiser [ __ ] right yeah
evil because it's just a guy looks like
a skull just teeth no nose and eyeballs
yeah and they're like yeah well yeah I
guess so well no they wouldn't be doing
that but
well it just stops yeah they were just
yeah and they run off they take the [ __ ]
they don't kill the guy then they so you
can't graft it back on I don't know if
they live I thinks I think they probably
can live like that you probably could
the shock might kill you or the blood
loss but if end I didn't see much blood
coming from them [ __ ] stops I think
maybe they wired it like a tourniquet
yeah
but evidently was a bunch of guys
working fast did it it's punishment yeah
I guess that's the one thing there's
another one where a guy was accused of
this is in Mexico guy was accused of
raping some kids so the the cartels the
local cartels are kind of like Robin
Hood's in a way they you know there's no
law and order of where they're where
they're operating so they're the cops
they grow you know so the the cartel
guys grabbed old boy stripped his ass
naked and was holding his arms like that
in the pit bull they let a pit bull
loose on him and that pit bull grabbing
right by the junk I just ripped it off
well yeah that's what yeah that's what
they did
neighbor laughing hmm
just all you guys you can find the [ __ ]
just the cartel victim video you look at
that [ __ ] on [ __ ] don't like you can
find all kind of [ __ ] find all that cuz
this [ __ ] right here uploaded all
kinds yeah he should do they internet
yeah he did get reported but they didn't
find him till later huh yeah so Luca man
yata that is actually not his real name
he was born Erik Clinton Kirk Neumann so
yeah as you said he was like a porn
actor model [ __ ] like that so he was
actually born in 1982 in Ontario and
legally changed his name to Luca Rocco
man yada
in August of 2006 now in 2003 he started
to appear in like gay porno videos he
also worked as a male escort he worked
as a stripper he was a pinup model in
there's like a gay magazine in Toronto I
think it's called fab and he appeared in
there like under a pseudonym now as far
as I know the first time that he
committed a crime we wasn't cute look
like a cracked-out Peter Pan with acne
yeah he was real he was a real zit face
yeah you know what I mean
so it's like he's in prison now man [ __ ]
you well face yeah it's like what is it
I guess they'd airbrushed it out but
yeah so the first crimes apparently that
he were was cop for in 2005 he was
convicted of one count of impersonation
three counts of fraud against like some
stores because he apparently
impersonated a woman to apply for a
credit card and he got a credit card and
then ran up like ten thousand dollars
worth of charges yeah
so he actually pled guilty to that and
got like um he got a nine-month sentence
and then twelve months probation now in
2007 and if anybody saw this show
because I'm guessing he was on TV so I
guess there was a reality show on out TV
called cover guy and I guess it was like
you know like a gay model competition
like a reality show and he was
apparently on there like competing to
win but he did not win that same year
2007 he also declared bankruptcy and
apparently owed seventeen thousand
dollars in various debts now for
whatever reason that same year rumors
started swirling around which maybe he
was responsible for that he was in a
relationship with the infamous Karla
Homolka who we did a show we did a show
about her and Paul Bernardo honor I
think it was on one of our Valentine's
Day shows about like killer couples
those two [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know
those two yeah yeah so brave all with a
girl knit well there's no evidence of
that here's the thing though he was
claiming to be gay but there were so
many pictures of him with like girls in
the hot tubs and [ __ ] and evidently
there was porn going on and he was just
a freak I think well or he might have
just been gay for pay
because that's like his common tail
maybe but he acted gay yeah but it
looked like it was kind of put on
to me it was over the top you know yes
he just seemed to be you know how I was
telling you about serial killers some of
their sociopaths and he just seemed to
be kind of fake and lizard-like yeah and
that everything is some kind of an act
he seemed like that too
yeah so nothing about him seemed genuine
so yeah everything was like a put-on
everything was gonna put on and he's
like a robot well and I do feel like too
because I mean he like I said he tried
to be on this [ __ ] reality show um
then he like I said there were rumors
that he was dating Karla Homolka I think
that he started those rumors even though
he denied it
um the Toronto Police actually reported
that he was but then they said no never
mind we don't really have any hardcore
evidence of that um but he had like a
whole bunch of plastic surgeries in 2008
he tried to be on another reality show
that's called plastic makes perfect so I
guess it was like you know let's show
like the Swan or something like that
where it's like you know [ __ ] yeah
was that never that remember that old
loser insel loser that it was also kind
of [ __ ] wimpy kind of pretty boy dude
talking about how awesome he was and the
women didn't love him he went on some
kind of damage shooting spree he's not
Roger
Elliot Rogers the poster child he was
like a tweaked out cracked out Elliot
Rogers but blond that's the way he kind
of went you know how they now he Rogers
kind of had that yeah robotic kana there
just was like a lot of parallels they
kind of reminded me
yeah like the same type of things like
the same kind of problem with whatever
is wrong with him
yeah yeah but yes not only did this
douche like trying to get on TV a bunch
of times but evidently he also had 70
different Facebook pages and 20
different websites that he had
registered under different names that he
used apparently to like spread rumors
and stuff about himself that's why I'm
saying that I think that he started that
rumor about the Karla Homolka thing so
it would get him like attention and then
they like denied it how the hell do you
have time to run
I don't even have time to look at mine
and I'm one you know I mean he's
dedicated to himself I guess so it's
like that yeah that's the thing so but
he the weird thing is that he was
maintaining them apparently
but then he was saying that oh all the
stuff and the rumors on oh that's not
true and that's just like cyber stalking
and like there people are picking on
victimizing himself yeah it was like
that kind of thing
I felt legibly I'm just saying was
allegedly that sounds about right yeah
but he sounds like that type of person
it sounds like he was gonna make it look
like all these people hated him but
really it was all his yeah it was all
him he was making his own he was kicking
up his own dust storm yeah that's
exactly what it make himself seem real
[ __ ] important yeah yeah so like own
a bunch of newspapers and having all
your newspapers attack you one of your
other newspapers yes that's a grandstand
that's [ __ ] funny what made him think
of that maybe that's a common tactic
that it might be that a certain type of
personality that celebrities minor
celebrities might do that yeah well like
I said it's any way to get attention and
the negativity gets attention more than
positivity sadly yeah so I kind of feel
like some people have figured this [ __ ]
out that that's how you get attention
yeah evidently a lot of [ __ ] this that
you know celebrities you know
celebrities who are famous for being
famous like Kardashians and all this but
that's the kind of [ __ ] that they do is
that it wouldn't surprise me that a lot
of a lot of their what they call press a
lot of their press is self generated
fake [ __ ] yeah well like I said it's all
about keep them safe keep them in the
decider consciousness sure I mean that's
what you do if that's your whole bread
and butter is people paying attention to
you yeah even then you don't have to get
people to pay attention to you by any
means necessary
yeah and if you're one of those
celebrities that is famous for doing
nothing for just being fair every now
and then you got to go next a person
like that and then just say items I
didn't do that that just rumors about
yourself right so you got to do that
[ __ ] cuz like I said any publicity is
good publicity everybody
that I think this way it used to work
I'm not sure it works that way anymore I
think social media because remember
remember back in the day when you know
the National Enquirer and the Sun was
the main way to get yeah that kind of
attention you know because he they were
so minor that they could show up on
television so everything was just you
know those magazines sold at the
checkout counter but I think the advent
of social media has made a lot of that
obsolete well yeah because you can just
like have a famous like Twitter again
yeah just Twitter's Twitter and you can
just go on there and so but I never got
involved that Twitter because most of
the [ __ ] most of most of YouTube is
complaining about Twitter I don't ever
go on there on yeah I have them I have a
13 o'clock account but when I post [ __ ]
on my blog or on YouTube it just posts
it on Twitter automatically so I never
go over there and look yeah so it does
post it on the on here now but I don't
listen even any interaction on Twitter
every now and then but not usually just
people making comments this on something
not I don't even remember the last time
I got a Twitter like that so like some
people will retweet it and stuff like
that but that's pretty much it
yeah most of our interaction is you know
on YouTube or or they'll send me emails
that are forcing or whatever a good
portion of the facebook video content as
people just talking about how bad the
people on Twitter are yeah I don't know
it just I don't know why she cared of
death getting kicked off a Twitter I
don't know why people don't have
anything better to do that's mean it's
like I I don't have enough hours in the
day to do everything I want to do is
like is bad and I can't imagine like I
said I only go on Facebook every few
days because it's like I just can't I
don't have time I just you just use a
messenger or to find somebody that I
already know to ask them what's going on
and like I know from the club yeah you
know that data stream where everybody's
just talking to each other I never look
at that [ __ ] no I hardly ever look at
they're in there fighting like [ __ ]
cats and dogs and the people you know
are talking [ __ ] about people that you
know yeah and you're like man well like
I said right I just use it like I said I
message people that I don't have their
email addresses you know it's useful for
that you know I kind of keep up with my
family because they live other places
and I post our shows
that's it and like I said I only go on
there a couple times we got Mexico
sending me booty pictures constantly
that's right yeah every time [ __ ]
Jair [ __ ] send you some message it's
girls with machine guns and booties he's
just trying to get your attention
yeah that's it she's like here's the
butt okay here's what it's a male
bonding thing
you know there's okay yes good this is
very funny because yeah like when we go
to independent bar where we go on
Saturday nights yeah her friend Lee it
was the bartender yeah um he's an ass
man also yeah so we'll sit in the front
bar cuz we get there really early and so
like him and Lee like you know we'll all
be talking and then suddenly they'll be
silenced yeah both of them will be
staring out the front window of the bar
cuz the front of the bar is all glass
and it's like wait it's downtown Orlando
he gave me the signal yes so like they
have like some kind of weird psychic
mail thing that's like hey ass and then
they both like shut up and then they
both like look out the window very very
funny there's a thing that guys do when
they see something and they want you to
look at it just like this it like this
he sees imagine you're me okay okay
not me I'm Lee right it's like yeah I
know I've seen him do that yeah it's
like they're not you're not that slick
about it cuz like I do see that exchange
yeah he's like hey and I'm like yeah and
you're like oh and it knows and I know
and I know at this point can we leave it
out I go Jane look at this every now and
then also you want to be like because we
get everybody walking by atome cuz
that's kind of like a make-work yeah
men like novelty alright now after that
let's talk about a gruesome murder okay
so yeah so like I said this [ __ ]
douchebag has all these [ __ ] other
accounts and stuff that he apparently
uses to abuse himself or get detention
or whatever the [ __ ] it is that he's
doing so at this stage here comes the
murder now the victim's name was Lynn
Jun he also went by the name Justin Lin
he was actually an international student
he was Chinese but he had been in
Montreal since 2011 he was a engineering
and computer science student he also
worked part-time at a convenience store
now apparently at the beginning of May
of 2012 he had just moved into like a
nearby apartment with a roommate now he
was last seen only a couple weeks later
like May 24th 2012 his friends said they
got a text message from about 9:00 p.m.
on that day and after that nothing like
he totally went missing and everything
so his boss like got worried when he
didn't show up for work the next day and
as a couple days went on and they didn't
hear from him so his friends like broke
into his apartment and found that he
wasn't there so they reported him
missing on May 29th now four days prior
to that on May 25th 2012 there was an 11
minute video and the title of this video
was one lunatic one ice pick this was
uploaded to best gore calm in this video
a naked
Asian man was tied to a bed frame
repeatedly stabbed with an ice pick and
a kitchen knife and then cut apart and
the dead body sexually molested he ate
part of a tube and yeah pretended to at
least I don't know if you yeah they said
actually they said that um that the the
guy who we now know was live pinata
what who would cut he cut pieces off the
body was like a knife and fork and got a
dog to chew on the body also um so
apparently in the Wikipedia page for
helpfully said in the background of the
video was unfortunately the very cool
new order song true faith is playing in
the background
also there was a Casablanca poster on
the wall that was visible in the
background now at the time that this all
happened you know the word was is that
that was that they were seeing each
other that there was a really yeah I
don't know like the the [ __ ] I read
didn't know that that aspect dropped
away and from what I remember what
happened was is that his Chinese parents
found didn't know when they found when
they
heard this gay thing no he wasn't gay
and you know the me that doesn't fly in
China yeah so I think the media dropped
dropped the gay angle from the story
maybe for the family in China but way I
remember this is that they were dating
yeah I don't know I don't know if they
were like that's how I remember it no
correct me if I'm wrong in it but that
was the last I heard yeah now that might
have been min Yatta
his name's manana right last name min
yatta yeah that month in manana lying
about it right that's what I mean that
you really only have his word Yeah right
I think it was came from him that yeah
that they were seeing each other yeah I
don't really know if they knew each
other prior to this or not so apparently
the the video that had been posted on
the internet I guess that was like a
longer version of that and the Canadian
police were able to get their hands on
it and apparently there was some
cannibalism going on in there you know
that was more clear so they were able to
determine that this was not a hoax that
if this was a real video and they also
noticed that I guess I guess Luca had
been like promoting like ten days before
this video went up it's almost like he
was like priming like the site he's like
you guys wait you see what's good yeah
he was like promoting it like more than
a week before it went up so shortly
after the video went up a guy in Montana
tried to report it to the Toronto police
but it didn't really get taken seriously
at the time also users on Best Score
tried to report it also and then May
29th the same day that jinlun was
reported missing or Lynne Jean was
reported missing there was a package
turned up at the headquarters of the
Conservative Party in Canada this
package was like it stunk really bad and
it was covered with blood and it had
like a red heart drawn on it inside was
a left foot hmm
and also there was another package that
had a left
and in it now this was actually
addressed to the Liberal Party but it
was intercepted at a post office before
it got there because I guess the first
one got there and then they were like on
the lookout for another one so those two
had been sent out a janitor at an
apartment complex also found a suitcase
that had a decomposing torso inside of
it that had been left in a garbage pile
in an alley apparently it had been there
since the 25th so when cops came and
searched the area they found more of the
human remains like body parts they found
a bunch of bloody clothes they found I
guess it was Lin Jun's like
identification so they knew who it was
so they found like a bunch of [ __ ] in
this alley they also got the footage
from the surveillance cameras that were
around this apartment complex and it
showed Luka Magnotta who they couldn't
identify them from the video but they
later found out that it was him they
showed him like bringing the garbage
bags outside in the suitcase and
everything and putting it there how old
were those tapes um no this was from
that this was a from only a few days
before okay yeah because he would he had
dumped the body out so surrounding
buildings have those tapes for at least
a few days before that are erased and
recycled yeah I guess it's not like it's
not like it used to be where it's like
you brought a tape and then you had to
like a record over it because it was
only so much I mean because memory Sochi
days so I feel like you could probably
did probably have months of it well yeah
I feel like and probably you had
probably you have to keep a certain
amount like just for just this purpose
like or like investigation purposes
maybe and in fact it might like
automatically upload to the cloud for 30
days or a year even and then like would
automatically erase I would imagine that
that's probably it is but I'm just
saying that yes you can nowadays it's
not really like I said if it just
uploaded straight to the cloud you might
be able to like you have some server
somewhere that'll keep it for like 90
days or whatever I've been hearing that
all these new signs and all these new
intersections that are going up or all
five g's and there's cameras on all of
them mate well most well
they already have cameras on them like
all the major intersections - yeah it's
like built-in because it happens
automatically though yeah everything's
recorded yeah I don't know how long to
keep it but I would admit I said I
imagine it's not forever but yeah just
in case like in this in this particular
case like you think at least be months
yeah I would say they could come back
and like find out
makes you wonder what they can do they
eye and facial recognition how good is
it yeah how good is all that stuff I
mean if they go I want to know where Tom
Ross is at all times you know I mean
they give him my face yeah am i showing
up driving through intersections on my
motorcycle even though I got my helmet
off I don't know I think that good see I
doubt it cuz you're I mean your helmet
is like pretty like dart like this yeah
the thing is the Hornet what if I'm
driving the car does that thing see me
and go there's Ross that [ __ ] that's
exactly what they're saying yeah I don't
know I don't know how good it is no it
is you would think that I mean I don't
know I feel like it's probably decent
but you know what if you're gonna be
good because that's what I mean it's
like what it's through the windshield
what if you have sunglasses on I'm gonna
leave a mustache how good could it
because they're people committing crimes
right now they can't catch they can't
catch them so it's like it can't be that
great
yeah plus like I said it's like it could
get messed up II think if you get all
our jobs and say oh no it's it's good
it's really good it's just that they
don't want you to know how good it is
they'd rather let all those criminals go
than to give up the depth what you
saying wait what what's the matter
Bayesian almost done basic yeah it's
like the in the world I know it is yeah
so yeah running out yeah she flicks her
little tail she says [ __ ] you yeah she's
like she's a little [ __ ]
yeah she's older she's yeah she's like
10 or something yeah she'sshe's snooty
she is a little snooty it's just it's
very funny how different the
personalities of our two hats are
they're like polar opposites she has
always been that way since she was a kid
she yeah she's like Paris Hilton she's
exactly like I can't believe I have to
endure this [ __ ] yeah she yeah she's
very much like that like when you don't
do something she wants
Jesus like yeah you ever heard I can't
just do that yeah she's just exasperated
with hell aiming or for not ridiculous
where the other kind the other kind is
just the opposite like baby cookie is
more like she's like a teeny baby just
consoling the wife she's like well she's
like a little baby but she's also like a
little um she's like a little tomboy
kind of looks like she always just want
the play and wrestle and [ __ ] like that
she gets kind of upset if you don't do
stuff you don't let her out she starts
crying but then she'll forget about it
after there should be like whatever I
still love you yeah yeah so yeah so the
video of this douche like dumping these
bodies in this alley
they said that guy looks like the same
guy that was captured on the
surveillance footage from a post office
where they think that the body parts
were mailed from right so they're
closing in on this dude so they figure
out which apartment the guy had come out
of which was apartment 208 at this
apartment building and that was the one
that Luca manana lived in now they went
in there they got a warrant and they
looked in there now he had already left
the apartment like that most of his [ __ ]
was gone however they did find blood on
a bunch of stuff they found like blood
on the mattress in the bedroom they
found blood on like the table in the
dining room on the refrigerator there
was blood in the bathtub which is
apparently where he cut the body up um I
saw the video yeah I think I've seen it
I saw the beard it's really poor quality
you can't tell what's going on I just
saw a little excerpt some of it and then
but what was more entertaining is I was
just read a guy's synopsis of it yeah
who watched it and he said that you know
the dude was a douchebag and he's trying
to make a huge production and trying to
come across like he's some kind of
criminal mastermind but every single
thing he did on that video on that tape
was something that he saw from a movie
or a music video yeah like some of the
stuff he was doing was like straight out
or like some off a Nine Inch Nails video
and then he did something else it was
kind of like something off of like like
a Hannibal Lecter seen a Hannibal Lecter
nothing was original about it the
quality of this is quality of the
filmography again
say was really shitty you know real
low-res and it and it's not even really
scary it's more like [ __ ] just
mundane and boring and kind of like
horrible but not like what you'd think
because the the way it's filmed it's so
low quality it just doesn't look real
yeah it doesn't look real
remember I was saying member Seven
Summits stuff that comes from most
serial killers you see it doesn't look
real
well yeah remember when the videotapes
of like those two [ __ ] bags that were
yeah on the whole thing Leonard Lake and
then heard lake and yeah they got girls
in there tell them what they're gonna do
them and it just looks like roleplay it
doesn't look real yeah well like I said
I guess because you're not usually in
that type of situation so it seemed it
has like a surreal quality I feel like
this does too because it's like it's not
every day that you see a person cut a
like murdered and cut up like your real
like on a video yeah but he was like
evidently accorded the synopsis that I
read that he pretended to eat part of it
but you could see that he was more like
acting like he was eating it yeah
although the cops did say that there was
some cannibalism going on in there but I
guess that wasn't part of like the one
that was uploaded but they had like a
longer version yes okay but yeah so so
they searched this dude's house if I'm
all his shit's gone mostly but there was
still they found like traces of blood
everywhere
they also said in one of the closets
somebody had written in red ink if you
don't like the reflection don't look in
the mirror I think he did chew on on
some of it but he was doing it for the
benefit of the camera not necessarily
because he wanted to do it he was just
putting on a [ __ ] show
yeah it's according to the person that
you know it's better just to read the
damn synopsis yeah yeah don't watch the
video through the [ __ ] yeah cuz I'm sure
it's on there it's on it's on but yeah
it just seems like I know it's horrible
to say but this seems like a guy that
just all you wanted was attention yeah
and he wasn't getting attention through
conventional me or like through being
cool or anything like that he was out
tending to be this [ __ ] super villain
so it's like edge lordy but like akin to
a horrible excuse killing people who was
doing all this [ __ ]
yeah it was fake he was doing it for
attention yeah he's like liquid about us
I'm doing you know it's it was like it
wasn't if you freaking like it wasn't
even really coming from within him it
was something he was pretend it's like a
pose yeah yeah pretending to be all this
yeah which in a way makes it worse
yeah like that poor [ __ ] guy he had
that robotic kind of quality to us cuz
he didn't have an identity yeah so he
was trying to kind of like invent one
yeah it does very clearly seem like that
so at this stage at the end of May they
were able to confirm that um that the
video as well as all the body parts that
they had found that had been mailed to
different places belong to Lin Jun who
had been missing since the 29th or had
been reported missing on the 29th now
they did figure out the suspect was Luca
manana but at that point he had got the
[ __ ] out of Dodge so they sent it like
they started like an international
manhunt now the package that it had the
foot in it that had been sent to the
Conservative Party headquarters there
was a note in there and it said that six
body parts had been distributed to
various places and it said that the
person that did it would kill again so
this was again more of his like self
aggrandizing kind of like oh you know
I'm the killer and I'm gonna do it again
now apparently there were notes in some
of the other packages too but I guess
the cops didn't release what they said
because they didn't want to encourage
copycat crimes so I don't think I don't
you know I don't think the public like
knows what those ones said now there was
actually another package that contained
the right foot and that showed up at st.
George's School on June 5th and then
there was a package with a right hand in
it that was sent to an elementary school
in Vancouver and they were able to
confirm obviously that these were also
blend Jane's body parts so they you know
they matched them all up using DNA and
everything like that they eventually
found at the poor guys head on the 1st
of July that year it was like left on
the like on the bank of like a lake or
something like that
so they put out an arrest warrant for
Luca man yada that by the Montreal
police and then the Royal Canadian
Mounted Police did like a Canada wide
thing obvious
the charges they were you know gonna
charge him with first-degree murder
obviously committing an indignity to a
dead body publishing obscene material
which is when they didn't really use all
that where do they go with these little
minor [ __ ] well because they want to
make sure that because they can add on
you know what I mean it's like what if
they get away with like the worst thing
they still want to be able to like have
something that they can put him in jail
for at least some time you know what I
mean
like so I can see why they do that like
they stack it up just like today's on
video he wasn't going in yeah that's
what I mean so they have like plenty of
[ __ ] evidence yes so he also got
chart mailing obscene indecent immoral
scurrilous material and criminally
harassing the prime minister and other
members of parliament because he has
sent the packages there so yeah so he
gets like the the Interpol like read
notice I guess that's like the top of
the website they put your [ __ ] face
all over this like everybody in the
world is looking for this [ __ ]
so um so they like anybody that catches
him like sent his ass box Canada cuz
we're gonna like [ __ ] kick his ass so
he apparently they found out later that
he had actually flown from Montreal to
Paris on May 26 which was the day after
that the video was posted he would used
a false passport at the time under the
name Kirk Trammell now they were able to
track his cell phone to a hotel there in
France in a town called manually but by
the time police got there he had already
left all they did they did find a bunch
of porno magazines in his hotel room so
that was nice yeah apparently he knew
some people in Paris and he had been
staying with him I don't think they knew
like who he was who he was or like what
the thing because he had met them like
several years before um so apparently
then like after he took off from the
hotel he got on a bus and went to
Germany like went to Berlin now in
Berlin he was apparently sitting in an
internet cafe yeah I saw the video of it
and watch it like reading news about
himself yeah and they [ __ ] found him
yeah the police found him yeah
poles I ran in there yep like a little
me SWAT team they got him yep and at
first he tried to give them a fake name
like no that's totally not me but they
didn't buy it and then they
fingerprinted him and they're like yeah
that's totally I mean you see the dude's
face you can't you can't mistake he's
very distinctive
and you can't mistake him for anybody
else yeah so apparently um they're like
okay well we're gonna extradite you back
to Canada you gotta fight that [ __ ] and
he's like no so they did like a
simplified extradition and they sent him
back to Canada and apparently they sent
him like on a military plane because
they didn't want him on that like a
commercial flight and they were like
they didn't want it in case it got
diverted or something really heavy or he
could do something bad or anything like
that so apparently like when when the
crime could apparently like when his
parents came over and [ __ ] like that
they were kind of pissed because they
thought maybe the crime had been
racially motivated and that like the the
that the public was not her the press
was not reporting that because
apparently there had been another murder
of like another Chinese student like you
know that same year prior year so you
know they thought what it's like Canada
not safe for us now like what the [ __ ]
is going on so those are kind of [ __ ]
but um yeah so so that happened but
there was also apparently the guy that
owned best gore calm where the video had
been posted he got arrested also oh
really and they charged him with
corrupting morals which is they said
that's a charge they don't usually use
yeah but they wanted to like punish
somebody for like allowing that [ __ ] to
be uploaded how much time they get um I
don't know actually he um I don't think
he he kind of got I think he just got a
fine or something like that is a still
there I don't know I didn't look at
murder I'm like I'm not looking that
back and then I've met Rebecca in the
90s there was like a predecessor to that
they had some weird-ass like in crime
photos on that that was like when I got
out of the arm is called gore gallery I
remember that yeah and gore gallery you
know most of it was just crime scene
photos they didn't yeah and some of them
were things that were taken from serial
killers yeah they had some weird [ __ ] on
it
I remember that site I think some of it
was famous some of it was like someone's
Jeffrey Dahmer's pictures yeah stuff
weird cuz like I said you can find this
[ __ ] if you look it's like it's out
there even sometimes accidentally look
cuz you know I've researched true crime
[ __ ] all the time and like sometimes I'm
like man I really hope there's not
nature oh man there's one thing that's
like you don't really want to see it but
then it's kind of there anyway
cuz I'm not gonna put safesearch on cuz
you know what I mean
I might like not get some [ __ ] actually
you know the worst [ __ ] that's out there
is Mexican cartel stuff I believe it
yeah that's the worst yeah cuz those do
to know what they're doing they're
working with efficiency and they work in
volume I mean you know they'll do 20
people yeah chop them up do weird things
with the skulls make them look like some
kind of damn Aztec [ __ ] sacrifice
displays you know the man just skulls
with bones and trying to give their
enemies the message don't [ __ ] with us
yeah you know and yeah you know maybe
some of that Jeffrey Dahmer stuff and
you see some crime photos that other
people did it looks amateurish these
dudes are just like you know if you I'm
kind of experienced you know when it
comes to field dressing deer you know
and hunting game and these dudes are
good with the human body I mean yeah
they can reduce a human down to the
pieces in minutes and you can tell that
they were dead they're very experienced
with it and they're not bashful I'm not
bashful dealing with deer I think with
with human beings I think it didn't ya
know I would hope it would be a little
bit different
oh yeah well I'm trying to think of the
environment that they're doing it and
they're doing it in a team and they're
doing it in the open or in in a safe
environment and probably with good
lighting so you pry doesn't have this
McCobb horror movie feel to it like when
you're field dressing a deer doesn't
have a horror movie feel to it right
it's just like you know cut and meat in
the kitchen yeah it's like that
you know the deer yes I mean you kind of
like feel the same I think they feel the
same way I think I think they don't
really have that I think they get used
to it yeah I think well I think what I
think that I think the emotional part is
what they're doing to a live person yeah
but a lot of that stuff that you see in
the photographs is post mortem a lot of
it yeah not all of it
but you know I've seen some bad photos
come from Mexico yeah some of it some of
it funny though they had his one cartel
who grabbed a bunch of snitches who
ratted on him
I guess they had pretty good control of
the town and they kill him it was just
men and women they made him take off all
their clothes and gave him a bunch of
body paint and they had to paint
themselves up like superheroes like
Batman a fighter man it had to be exact
anything they walked him down the middle
of the town there's your superheros town
dude making fun of them yeah you want to
be superheroes there's your superheroes
hey God dude stand in there drew you
know painted up like spider-man I don't
know the whole story about somebody in
the audience might know the story that
one that was pretty famous yeah yeah so
uh so this douchebag he's put on trial
and he insisted on trial by jury and he
also pled not guilty but he did get
indicted on all the charges and
everything like that um so as you were
mentioning before this douche bag is
also allegedly the person who made there
was a series of videos that have been
posted to YouTube and this was starting
in 2010 there were several of them and
they were all cruelty to toward cats
yeah there was one that was called one
boy two kittens which showed a man who's
apparently his face was not in the video
he was suffocating to kittens with a
vacuum cleaner you see that now as I
said before that apparently the Netflix
documentary that's coming out about it
they're kind of like talking about this
and how they identified this guy because
a whole bunch of animal rights groups
had seen these videos and started like
all these Facebook groups trying to find
out who this [ __ ] was like they
raised like all this money and they were
like trying to find out who he was and
they're pretty sure now that that's you
know that was him the one I saw he was
sitting on a bed and he had a little
kitten a little bitty kitten and he put
it inside of like a 1 gallon ziplock bag
and it was in it used up all the air
poor you know terrible I can't watch
like a terrible terrible it's like we
started once watching it like it was
beautiful you know that man I go that
kid has like man [ __ ] what a [ __ ]
I need to hand him over to those cartels
yeah he apparently also made one of a
Python like a Burmese python eating a
kitten oh yeah
I'm assuming they but I mean I'm sure
they're somewhere but I'm sure YouTube
would has taken them down I mean yes
this was awesome buddy somebody's got
him I'm sure archive yeah and apparently
like some of the animal rights groups
that were trying to catch him what they
did was they were trying to draw him out
by accusing him of that very famous
Hollywood sign murder like that guy I
think his name was uh Harvey or Harvey
Medellin or whatever that guy's name was
that they found dead by the Hollywood
sign so apparently this animal rights
group like went on Facebook and accused
him of that because they wanted to find
out who it was like before they found
out who it was like I said they're not
entirely sure but they're pretty sure
that Luca man yata is also response one
whose face was in the video it might
have been yeah I mean but but it might
be a thing where there's a bunch of them
yeah maybe was like a bunch of murders
like they're like oh we're not entirely
sure it's ambien whatever so yeah that's
uh that's that [ __ ] dirtbag um so we
probably gone on and we're about the
halfway point so we will take a break
right now and when we come back we will
talk about Bruce MacArthur who was a
very prolific serial killer like I said
allegedly started serial killing in his
late 50s early 60s but they think that
he might be responsible for a bunch of
murders in the 1970s well it's late
enough for me to get a drink yeah and
we'll also talk about the horrible
horrible murder of Tim Buckley and
before the end of the show so I'm gonna
take a break right now and we'll be
right back in just a few minutes what
are we doing
Oh what's the foot fetish yes okay oh
yeah oh my goodness oh my goodness I
know I know I know welcome Dale here I
see
oh my goodness she just loves those feet
you love beat I don't know why you like
no oh you're ruining it winning it what
you doing yeah what's he doing yeah yeah
how's Pookie this morning how are you
doing beautiful Hey look at that little
face look at that little face oh yeah I
wanted a bridge under bridge just go
away it's like I look happy
there's my knee and I shot it back you
love true crime I love true crime and
I've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume three is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
Caddy murders the carry babies case the
Frog Boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
all right we're back talking about
Canadian crimes now let's talk about
Bruce MacArthur who this is actually
fairly recent that they caught him they
really only I think they only arrested
him in early 2018 and he only recently
pled guilty to eight counts of murder in
early 2019 so as I said this is a fairly
recent case and most of the people he
murdered it happened between 2010 and
2017 this was a guy who apparently was
targeting gay men in Toronto's gay
village you know it's like one
particular like a few particular blocks
where like all the bars and [ __ ] are so
apparently he was stalking this area and
taking victims from there and also
picking up victims from various like
dating sites like gaming gay male dating
sites and things like that now like I
said um this is a guy who when they
caught him in early 2018 he was 66 years
old now the strange thing about this I
was watching this show it's like a
Canadian show called um the Fifth Estate
and they were talking about this and
they said you know um
there actually was I mean this was eight
murders that they know of they said but
actually back in the 70s there was a
whole bunch of other murders and
disappearances that happened in the same
area and almost always almost all of gay
men and they are speculating that Bruce
McArthur might have been responsible for
those as well because he would have been
in his mid to late 20s at that time how
him I kind of feel like it probably was
- they don't have any definitive
evidence particularly because like the
crimes that happened a long time ago you
know
homosexuality had only just been
decriminalized I believe in 1969 in that
part of Canada so it was still very much
it was kind of scary because they showed
they said in that area they used to do
like a nothing they didn't do like a
pride parade yet but they did like a
drag show and ladies like a parade and
stuff and even in the early 80s like all
these people would come to like throw
rocks at them and [ __ ] like that call
them [ __ ] and [ __ ] like yeah yeah so
it's like it was bad and it's like and
people were like afraid like people in
the alleys like you know that we're
coming to and from the show we'd get
beat up and [ __ ] like that so there was
like a lot of animosity toward the gay
community like even that late in the
late 70s early 80s so a lot of times
when people that were coming and going
from the bars would get beat up or sit
like that a lot of times they wouldn't
report it because they didn't think that
cops would do anything about it and it
really does seem like sadly it seems
like that fear was partially justified
because it does seem like a lot of the
crimes were not investigated even when
they were reported they were doing the
same [ __ ] to us true yeah this is
Frankenstein [ __ ] villagers with the
pig [ __ ] off loans you know and it's
like it was just making me so mad like
watch of this [ __ ] but save me so
apparently like a lot of disappearances
and murders happen back then in the 70s
too but it wasn't really like
investigated to any great extent so
there is some speculation and I'm kind
of leaning toward this - like I said
they don't have any definitive evidence
but they are still exploring this
possibility and like going through all
the cold-case files and stuff I believe
it's like 600 cold-case files because
once they caught Bruce McArthur and
noticed like his MO and like the types
of victims he targeted and stuff like
that they're like okay well it's very
likely that this guy was probably
responsible if the ones that happened
back in the 70s as well and just got
away with it because it wasn't
investigated so all Bruce MacArthur was
born in Ontario in 1951 was raised on a
farm now apparently his parents were
very well well-regarded I don't think
there was anything like weird about his
childhood in or anything like that um
they were known as like really they they
fostered like a lot of like orphan kids
and stuff like that so they were like
very well-liked in the
hood and very light well looked upon
because of that I had a good reputation
and whatnot um you know that nothing
really weird from Bruce's like school
the time at school or anything like that
he went to like a one-room schoolhouse
so I guess this was like pretty rural
back in the 50s um you know other
students said he was you know he was
kind of like a tattletale like trying to
be a teacher's pet like telling on
people and stuff like that because I
guess he didn't get along with the other
channel seeker so yeah so he kind of had
that type of personality now there was a
little bit of a kind of conflict between
his parents because apparent because
they were different religions I think
he's like his mom was an Irish Catholic
and his dad was Scottish Presbyterian
and apparently they were both super
religious so there was like a lot of
like infighting and stuff and apparently
Bruce was kind of on his mom's side for
a time but then because his dad used to
pick on him because he thought that he
was gay which he did without him what
she did come out of the gate later but
like the dad was like picking on him
about it like saying he wasn't a man and
all this other kind of [ __ ] so um so
Bruce kind of sided with his mom and
like these kind of religious disputes um
so you know at the time he goes to high
school he meets this girl I don't know
if this is high school secondary school
I don't know if that's high school or
college because I know that like the
Canadian system is a little bit
different um he starts dating this girl
named Janis Campbell and they both
graduated in 1970 and they later got
married when Bruce was 23 years old so
yeah so he starts get he gets like a
regular job he gets he starts working
for Eaton's department stores he was
like a buyer or a buyer's assistant or
something like that um and he worked in
downtown Toronto now it so happened and
this is what makes me think that he was
probably responsible for the [ __ ] back
in the 70s too because he started
working at Eaton's department store in
1973 right and where the what what they
now call its I know it's a dumb name but
they do call it the gay village that's
what's called in Toronto like the part
of the town where like all the bars and
stuff are and it wasn't called that then
because it wasn't like a codified area
that was just kind of like where a lot
of the gay people would hang out like
kind of on the down-low
so he only worked like a block or two
from there right around the time that
all of those murders and disappearances
were happening in the 70s so that makes
me a little suspicious so in the mid
1970s he'd been working at this
department store for a little while his
dad gets a brain tumor and goes to a
nursing home now apparently his mom
started going out with another guy cuz I
guess the dad was dying never and she's
like hey yeah there's something like
that now you know at this point it seems
like Bruce kind of reconciled with his
dad and then got pissed off at his mom
so there was like a whole weird family
diamond dynamic thing going on there now
apparently his even though he's dad had
a brain tumor his dad lived longer than
the mom like the mom died in 1978 I
think and then the dad died like a
couple years later like 1981 now the mom
had cancer so I don't know why kept I
don't know how that happened but yeah
didn't go as she planned I guess not
so 1979 probably breaking up anyway yeah
well like I said they had like um you
know their their religious views were
yeah a lot different so and he said they
used to fight a lot about that so Bruce
and his wife cuz like I said he was
married they bought a house in a suburb
called Joshua I think I'm pronouncing
that right I saw it on a documentary and
I can't remember um
now by 1981 they'd had two kids they had
a daughter named Melanie and a son named
Todd and so Bruce apparently you know
he's got a wife and a family now he's
gay but he's you know back then you kind
of kept it on the down-low
right so he's like trying to keep it
under wraps he starts working for the
church apparently to try and pray the
gay away I don't know what he was trying
to do but he was I guess he was like
trying to forget about it so he gets
very involved in the church and [ __ ]
like that and another thing that makes
me think that maybe he was doing some
[ __ ] in the 70s too was that in 1978
when he was work of ratings department
store after that he started working as a
traveling salesman for like this Sox
company
a sock company so he like got to travel
all around by himself
like trying to sell the socks like a
different department stores you know
what I mean so he was on the road a lot
with no supervision so that's something
that a lot of serial killers yeah have
that type of job where they're just kind
of like driving around and like
targeting people so I kind of feel like
this [ __ ] that happened in the 70s was
probably him
because he was you know driving all over
the place now by the time they excuse me
by the time that the early 1990s rolled
around it appeared that he was like
tired of being in the closet so he
actually did come out to his wife they
did like stay living in the same house
but he started to you know carry on
relationships with men and stuff like
that
now even though they stayed married
apparently they started getting into
like all these financial problems
because their son Todd who was a
teenager by this time this is like early
90s mid 90s their son Todd was like
constantly making obscene phone calls he
was always getting caught for it so he
was always like in legal trouble so I
guess they always had to pay for like
legal costs and show like that and it
was apparently like a big financial
drain on them because I don't know I
don't know what the wife did but she he
was working as you know the garment
business or whatever and I guess he
hadn't been doing all that well so they
actually ended up having to file for
bankruptcy in 1999 even though he had
actually moved out like they had they
were still married I think that they had
separated and Bruce ended up moving to
Toronto because where they lived it was
like kind of like a small town and there
was no gay bars and stuff so I guess he
figured since he was out he was going to
start hanging out in the burgeoning gay
village which there's these two streets
called Church Street and Wellesley I
guess and that's kind of where all the
gay bars are and like all that other
kind of stuff so he moved into an
apartment around there and started
hanging out in the bars and kind of
becoming a regular and all this other
kind of [ __ ] now apparently he got into
like a four-year relationship with
another man for a little while but then
they broke up you know right around the
time that his divorce from his wife is
being finalized
he apparently had some mental problems
at this time likes depression and stuff
like that he went on Prozac and then
later he started working as a landscaper
and eventually would start his own
landscaping business now the first sign
of trouble that anyone knew of happened
on Halloween of 2001 now apparently
Bruce had met a sex worker on a chat
line and so the guy says oh well why
don't you come over and see my halloween
costume or whatever cuz it was Halloween
like I said so he goes over to the guy's
apartment and for whatever reason I
don't know if they had an argument or
what the problem was but he started
hitting the guy in the back of the head
like with an iron pipe that he just
happened to have with him so I guess he
was maybe planning this should I not
killing it I kind of feel like it yeah
so um apparently that he knocks the guy
out he didn't kill him though and
apparently then like Bruce like took off
I don't know if you like freaked out or
whatever so the guy woke up and
obviously called 9-1-1 as you would and
he gets taken to the hospital he had to
get a whole bunch of like stitches on
the back of his head and his fingers
were all [ __ ] up and he had to like do
physiotherapy and [ __ ] like that
he must have he must have tried to rape
the guy oh you know I mean yeah didn't
quite go down the way he thought it was
gonna go down you know and he ended up
having to hit the guy with that pipe
yeah and that spoiled his mood or
something maybe that's what it wasn't
expected it he didn't expect it to
happen that way well they're like I said
that I'm out of here
it does seem weird that he might have
had an iron pipe with him though we
assume now do it did it say that it had
that I mean that's what I read on the
source that he carried it around with
them so well maybe her thing to care
nobody he did plan on killing the guy
with the iron pipe but it didn't happen
in the way that he had not ordered in
the way that he thought it was going to
maybe spoiled it and maybe they do yell
do maybe the dude made a lot bunch of
noise yelled out he thought the
neighbors had heard so he so he started
to split it might have been something
like that now the weird thing about it
though was that even though he took off
like the guy which the hospital and
everything like that like Bruce for this
he turned himself in
um although he claimed when they asked
him why he done it he said oh I don't
really remember you know what I mean I
don't really remember that or I don't
remember why I did it but he didn't he
yeah he did turn himself in still have
some kind of panic attack he thought he
was caught yeah so he went and
preemptively turned himself in try to
make himself right mitigate mitigated
make yourself look innocent yeah maybe
he thought that that guy could ID him
and knew where he lived that kind of
[ __ ] was something like that
yeah maybe it was but yeah so he so he
did plead guilty to the charges which
were you know assault with a weapon
assault you know assault causing bodily
harm whatever now he actually only got
um like a two year sentence yeah um so
there was a thing where I guess they
thought at the time that he probably
would not riaf end like but there was
some controversy about that because I
guess like the prom crop the Crown
prosecutor was like you know I you know
this is a conditional thing and it's
like him after they let him out he
probably won't do it again bla bla bla
um you know they they tried to kind of
explain it away too by saying oh maybe
the reason that he did it was because
they were both on poppers and also I
guess Bruce McArthur at the time was on
like anti-seizure medication and they're
like maybe there was some kind of medica
you know the medicines like reacted with
one another um you know and maybe that's
what explained it so you're just trying
to ration yeah so it's like by the time
they kind of got through that they
didn't think that he was going to
reoffending gave him two years so yeah
so um he actually didn't go to prison he
actually just went under house arrest
for a year and then he had like a curfew
for six months and then he had like
three years of probation after that now
he was also not allowed to go down to
the gable and she was not allowed in
that area of the city he had to and he
had like there was a restraining order
against him for uh you know for the
victim he couldn't go within like three
zone you know whatever he was yeah he
wasn't allowed to be gay and he was not
allowed to solicit male prostitute
that's illegal anyway
I know I know and this was in the 90s
okay it had been decriminalized in 69 I
believe it was 60 70 no I meant um no
prostitution I think Oh excellent in in
in Canada yeah well most places here too
yeah yeah but um yeah so he was also he
wasn't allowed out any firearms all that
other kind of stuff he was allowed to
purchase drugs or particularly poppers
and whatnot so he also had to submit his
DNA to a database now unfortunately this
apparently didn't stop him because he
went on to do even [ __ ] worse kind of
[ __ ] so um the weird thing about it was
then in 2014 he actually got a
suspension of the conviction and they
like expunged it from his record so that
if you did a criminal check on him after
2014 that assault charge would not come
up yeah
I'm not really entirely sure why they
did that um I I don't know I'm just
saying that that's what they did
he's probably a first offender well if
he was yeah well then and and they
thought there were mitigating
circumstances because of the medication
and because then maybe he just flipped
out and he had never like done anything
like that bloody block most countries
allow a first offender that if the
charge happens and then he goes a
certain amount of time with that or
Neary without any yeah arrests or
convictions after that it's kind of
hidden yeah that way you got that lady
Thiang in case it was an accident right
that kind of well in case it was a
one-off thing because some people do
like one horrible thing and then they
don't do it again but it's like most
guys with criminal offenses are multiple
offenders it goes way back like 98 98
percent of them are [ __ ] multiple
offenders by the time they're 18 yeah
and it's a lifelong trend yeah so you
know they're just trying to they're
trying to give an out for them you know
accidental [ __ ] in the one offs yeah
yeah yeah because I mean you know [ __ ]
happens something yeah I guess so yeah
so apparently in 2002 while he was still
going through all the [ __ ] with the
assault charge
Bruce McArthur registered on a bunch of
like gay dating sites including and I
love the [ __ ] names and
these um but there's I guess there's a
fetish one like BDSM that's called recon
which I really like yeah he also
registered on a bunch of other ones my
favorite name of which is Man Jam there
was also one called
scruff there's one called silver daddy's
grinder everyone's heard of that one
bear Forrest I like that Daddy hunt I
like that one it's because he was into
bears apparently or guys with beards and
stuff um so he also had like a like a
Facebook profile and I guess all the
pictures of it he's like look at all the
parties I'm at look at all the [ __ ]
nightlife he's always at clubs and [ __ ]
like that so there was always like
pictures of him now apparently he had a
thing for like I said he had a thing for
bears like he had a thing for guys with
beards and [ __ ] he also had a thing for
South Asian men or Middle Eastern men um
a lot younger he liked them a lot
younger than him cuz I mean at this
point let's see he's probably in his 50s
I think at this time um so yeah he liked
really young guys they got wears they
got otters they got all kinds of [ __ ] so
he dudes are gonna make gays are gonna
make up names for [ __ ] describe that do
you say otter you know yeah well at
least it makes sense I mean when
somebody says someone's a bear you know
you know yeah so yeah so he had by this
time he had like moved into like near
the gay neighborhood and everything and
you know and he was hanging out in all
the bars now he kind of got a reputation
around for being into like you know
fetish stuff BDSM you know being into
like rough stuff whatever um and he kind
of got in a little bit of trouble now
and again like he apparently got kind of
abusive toward somebody like he was in a
coffeehouse or something like that and
somebody said something but him he like
freaked out and he like pushed all the
glasses off and like was getting all mad
about it and he got kicked out he's too
baby
yeah so so he had some little rage
issues and [ __ ] like that however um
other people kind of remembered him as
like a really nice friendly dude like he
was totally you know they
think anything about legislation he
seemed very generous and very kindly I
think he even like played Santa Claus
like at the mall and [ __ ] like that like
during Christmas and whatever yeah so as
I said he had opened a landscaping
business the name of his business was
artistic designs which you know that's
not very original but whatever um yeah
and a guy that had worked for him for a
little while like I guess he was kind of
like a contractor and he said yeah he's
like this guy it's like yeah he has this
landscaping company but it was just like
this tiny like old van and all his tools
were old [ __ ] like that apparently he
did okay job I guess but you know but
they said he he always had like two guys
with him they said there was an older
white man with him who it looked like
they were like a thing like they were
boy friends um and also that there was
another guy that was like a young guy
who was like Middle Eastern maybe that
was always with them also so they don't
know like who that was but yeah um
apparently he had apparently Bruce had
like a lot of clients that were old
ladies cuz they just thought he was the
coolest so I guess he was like really
charming toward old ladies and they kept
hiring him to do their landscaping
because he was super charming I guess or
he could be and like I said he also
during the Christmas season he played
Santa Claus there's pictures of him in
his little Santa Claus suit like sitting
in the mall and he even like made [ __ ]
for charities and all this other kind of
[ __ ] so apparently like I said he still
had this teenage son that was making all
these obscene phone calls he actually
ended up going to jail for 14 months or
whatever and when he got out one of the
conditions of the son getting out
because the you know at this point Bruce
and his wife had like divorce and it was
kind of contentious there for a little
while so when Todd gets out of jail he
has to go live with Bruce at his dad and
like work at the landscaping company for
a little while now apparently a friend
of Todd's came over to the house one
night and said went in Bruce's bathroom
like to use the bathroom and there was
like pictures of naked men with boners
like all over the walls at the back you
have to understand some if you got a hit
you gonna have hitches a naked man they
better have
yeah you would thank you and they said
and the friend said that it's like he
recognized some of the guys so it's like
I guess well that had been in the house
or like there anything braces and briefs
just thought it was funny like when they
said something about he's like yeah
that's the motor pictures all of you
coming right at you what a weird thing
to like just paste all over your
bathroom it seems like that not very
glad that's not it's not weird cuz think
about it if a guy if a guy could have a
bunch of pictures of women with their
titties and [ __ ] he'd do it true yeah
but like all over your bathroom though
it's like that other people are gonna
use he's not thinking that way that's
just trophies I guess that's his
trophies yeah that's just games
everybody a guy's gonna do that I guess
you know yeah but put boners up there
yeah I guess it's no different than
having like but like I said it's it it's
not weird like having like pictures all
over your wall it's pictures on the like
a bathroom that other people are gonna
and you're just like yeah sure use my
bathroom don't mind the erection boy he
pride doesn't foot he probably doesn't
think there's gonna be any women going
in there he's probably thinking it's
gonna be go the game in you don't be
like oh yeah yeah you know look at all
the better okay yeah so you know that's
what he's thinking yeah yeah I've got to
put yourself in his shoes I would rather
not do that you can see this yeah we got
we got gay subscribers they can tell us
all about the boner pictures that they
have I'm sure they make sure they got
boner pictures so okay so at this point
while all of this stuff was going on um
people had started to disappear I'm
getting pictures of people's asses from
Mexico that's true you just did that
before yeah so you know it's just random
it's just you know it's a different
preference yeah like I said that's not
weird it's not weird having pictures
it's weird putting them all over a
bathroom than other people he's a guy
he's not thinking like a normal human
being yeah clearly
you guys okay I don't know I don't know
you're not thinking like well maybe they
weren't framed it just depends on what
the situation they weren't frightened
it's not like classier yeah you know it
was like it's like paste and centerfolds
a little like the garage when I run in
in the bathroom yeah that's it they're
taking a leak looking at the boner
pictures that's what I do like put a bit
yeah I can in a bathroom there yes
whatever
yeah but yeah so right around the time
that all this was going on people have
started to disappear from Toronto's gay
village okay so the police are starting
to get a little alarmed and have started
like a investigation which they called
proj project Houston so that as I said
they they first started the
investigation because apparently there
was this guy his name was scanned and
never aa tanam and he disappeared in
September of 2010 and they looked for
him but couldn't find him they suspected
that he had been murdered but they
couldn't find his body now there had
also been a posting on the [ __ ]
Internet it's a wonderful place isn't it
there's apparently a cannibal website I
don't know if it's still there or not
called Zambian meat yeah dad Zambia you
don't mean my wife and yes over that
bush meat some of that I suppose yeah
yeah well in that long pig
so apparently someone had posted on this
website that they had killed and eaten a
man in Toronto now because the police
connected these two because this man had
gone missing and then because somebody
had made this post about eating a man in
Toronto so they kind of say okay well we
need to start like so they started this
whole investigation called Project
Houston now interestingly because of the
cannibalism an angle and everything like
that they actually thought that Luke man
yada the guy we were just talking about
might have been involved in this [ __ ] so
they investigated him for this also so
there's still you know so to
[ __ ] running around so so
apparently the first guy that they were
looking at was his dude named James
Brunton and he had been under
surveillance and other this kind of [ __ ]
now they couldn't get him on any murder
however out during all the surveillance
everything like that they did find
enough evidence to convict him of
manufacturing and distributing child
pornography
so he wasn't like a great guy or
anything like that but they couldn't
find any evidence that he had murdered
anyone but okay cannibal sight are we
talking about like those vores see that
I don't like I don't want to look yeah
they don't actually ever do it
pop that was yeah well it apparently
Bruce McArthur like after they caught
him apparently he had done this kind of
[ __ ] to where they had that whole kind
of haze like hey you have to sign this
contract and that I that means that I
can eat you I'm sorry if you're
fantasizing about eating somebody yet in
my mind it's only a matter of time it
does really say I'm gonna beat your
tempted that's the thing it's like it's
really that it's kind of like a hard
thing too because people watch like
[ __ ] up porn and never do that [ __ ] in
real life
yeah so I feel like you can't but
there's a whole lifestyle you go out in
you're buying ovens for it and you're
talking about it that's what they do
yeah that's kind of like if you have a
dude who's constantly talking about
children you know what I mean yeah I
having sex with children and buying [ __ ]
for children and it's only a matter of
time if you ask me yeah before he tries
something just saying although it
bothers me because it's like how okay so
like how many people that are on
websites like that you don't know how
many people are on those websites and
all they do is like fantasize or trade
stories or stuff like that because they
only catch the people that do it in real
life what percentage of them actually do
it of them actually I bet you it's about
I bet you it's about 5% that seems it
but you know what assumption what's that
I think that seems a pretty reason I'm
thinking
probably not like 5% because I think
there are a lot of people that have
fantasized about being a serial killer
never do it yeah but I don't know if
they go so far you know I mean but yeah
I mean there's a there's a fine line
between like fantasize like you're just
writing stories you're thinking about it
or where it seems like you're actually
like some pairing up stocking up
prepared like oh I'm gonna go buy a
chain saw I'm gonna go like buy all the
stuff you know what's weird of a body
even though what's weird is that's the
serial killers the real serial killers
don't do that real serial killers
[ __ ] kill people and they're not
they're kind of unprepared for it most
of the time it's like super early moment
because it was just of an opportunity
and then they just do it again so it's
almost kind of like it is a different
profile when it comes to serial killing
that's what I mean that's why it's like
hard to but identify them because what a
serial killer isn't always a [ __ ]
cannibal they're sad about fetishized
cannibalism which I think that might be
I think that's dangerous if you ask me
I'm it's definitely not mentally healthy
I don't think yeah that seems like I
mean I'll go a pretty long way like yeah
you know healthy with what's people's
porn preferences are because I know like
some people are into some weird [ __ ] and
I'm fine with that so I got this
constantly Wandy somebody is not right
if you ask me I think you need to go see
some help I mean that's when there's a
difference between a realistic fantasy
of like eating up or like a cannibal
would eat a person yeah or sometimes
there's a fetish for people that they
have a fetish for like somebody who's
like really small like they're an ogre
and like they want to be eaten by like
which is more fantasy based which I
don't think there's like the time is
your sanity Sam in my dream right leg
yeah I know this when I was a little kid
when I was a little kid out in
California I used to play up the hose
and I would [ __ ] dig you know my dad
would drive my dad crazy cuz I'd [ __ ]
dig channels in a little yard uh can ya
dig the whole yard I'd have [ __ ]
lakes and streams and [ __ ] you know are
we miss your earring well I had a dream
I was out there playing like that yeah
you know I mean and I had a big river
going and I stood up I'm a little kid
you know I'm like seven six I'm probably
six
five six I stand up and here comes down
the big old river [ __ ] huge Spanish
galleon lucky I saw wooden model of a
ship yeah you know I mean it's with the
sails and [ __ ] prob about three or four
feet long and that's that's what I saw
it inspired me for the dream it comes
down on the damn River that I'd made
that I just made and I'm looking at it
and standing on a deck as Yosemite Sam
and he's firing cannons at me and guns
[Laughter]
and all of a sudden for a second I felt
like Godzilla
Godzilla's fighting the army tanks yeah
right
and I reached down and I grabbed you
send me Sam and I bit the top of his hat
and burned myself on that cherry cherry
filling he was full of cherry full of
the truth I looked down and there was
red like blood that was cherry filling
because you know because you burned
yourself at McDonald's almost damn
cherry yes and now what am i doing you
know why am i eating your sim yeah yeah
yeah the first time you told me that I
left my ass I mean that needs to be like
a short animated film that was on his
Spanish galleon coming at me that was
weird as the dream I had when I was
really little about how I was like
running through this room and it had
like all these [ __ ] fake animatronic
alligators like coming out of the floor
was even water they were just coming out
of the floor and I was afraid they were
gonna eat me so there was like this
little bitty like patch of hair it
looked like a band-aid but it had like
hair on it and I stood on top of it and
somehow I fit on even though it was like
little tiny and then it flew over old
and I was flying over all the alligators
here indicating I had a dream run the
same time that I ate you Cindy Sam was
standing out in the front yard is
watching the airplanes coming landed in
LAX this is what I was living
California's little kid you know and I
was watching the planes and one of the
planes came right towards me it was
coming close it was crashing right at me
crashed into a tree reached up and
caught it it was about five feet long
Jim your
yeah now looked into the side all the
people the passengers are looking at me
wow that saved us thanks man you see
what what inspired me on that one is
that I had a model of a of a passenger
jet yeah you know it wasn't that big but
you know it was about that big I mean
your kid you just think of some wild
[ __ ] you have crazy dreams yeah you do I
want my dreams I've never had a crazy
dream says that's crazy it's the ones I
have man I had a dream I was flying over
Los Angeles in like a fight with in a
10-8 you know a dr1 Fokker triplane and
a Fokker triplane and when Stan was
about 8 feet there's a little miniature
[ __ ] [ __ ] tried like a Red Baron
flying over Los Angeles and that thing
were you Snoopy
that's right I got it yeah I know I had
it
see here's the thing I had two models
remember nerf nerf maids and model
airplanes that actually flew you put
them together and one I remember those
one of them was a soft wet camel I had
that one and I also had to try my
brother had that and I loved that damn
try plane they came out and you put him
together they yeah they all clipped
together it was never cool that they
didn't look totally realistic but they
were neat it's not yeah and I love the
[ __ ] Fokker triplane so when I was a
fluke I was a little kid that would end
up in the pin in the other p40 tomahawk
yeah when I was a little kid they asked
me what I wanted to be when I grew up
and I said a p40 tomahawk he wanted to
be a airport I wanted to be an airplane
not he didn't want to fly an airplane he
want to be an airplane it had to be a
[ __ ] it had to be a p40 tomahawk in
the [ __ ] Flying Tigers configuration
with the [ __ ] with the [ __ ] shark
teeth the shark teeth yeah the mercenary
I used to be fascinated by that fact
because my dad had like a whole bunch of
those like what works like all the you
know airplanes of war and [ __ ] like that
nice I love that [ __ ] yeah that was
an American I'm a mercenary unit serving
[ __ ] you know Chiang kai-shek yeah and
you know they came from the Army Air
Corps but yeah there's just there's just
to me that was the ultimate in badassery
plane with [ __ ] and I wanted to be
that plane
I just wanted to be Indiana Jones oh
yeah okay but yeah alright so um in June
of 2013 this task force project Houston
they also found two of their
missing-persons cases that they thought
might be linked to this whole situation
now these two guys were named
bassir faizi and hamid cai que han now
these were they were off both from South
Asia and both had disappeared from you
know the gay village between 2010 and
2012 now both of these men were married
and had families but were kind of
leading double lives like their families
did not know they were gay so they were
like sneaking around you know what I
mean like living a double life because
they were afraid to tell their families
and had disappeared from that area
now Bruce McArthur ended up getting
linked with these missing-persons cases
through his all the dating apps that he
was signed up for apparently he had been
according to witnesses he had been in a
brief romantic relationship with skinned
and a Bharat Nam who was the first guy
that disappeared in 2010 and that he had
also like been friends with one of the
other guys that disappeared so when
police interviewed Bruce MacArthur he's
like yeah yeah he knew those gonna but
he tried to like kind of play it off he
said he knew them from like this bar
called the Black Eagle and he's like you
know yeah I you know hung out with them
it's like one of them works for him for
a short time blah blah blah but he tried
to like kind of downplay like the
[ __ ] you know the Association there
um now at this point they didn't have
any bodies and they didn't have enough
evidence to link him at this point they
were interviewing him as though he was
like a witness you know what I mean like
they weren't necessarily like thinking
he was a suspect they just think well he
knew these guys so maybe he has some
information that he can part but like I
said they didn't really have any other
evidence to link him to the men going
missing
now another guy named Andrew kinsman
also disappeared in June of 2017 and
this was the day after like the Gay
Pride Festival that they have in Toronto
he was last seen kind of walking around
his apartment and I guess he went
missing and like his friends wonder
where do they hadn't seen him for a
couple of days so they went into his
apartment
and they found that
is like prescription medication was
still there like he had a cat who hadn't
been fed or get any water in several
days and they're like look this is a guy
who he had lived in the area for a very
long time he was considered like he was
well known like everybody knew him he
was a bartender he like had volunteered
like for the people with AIDS Foundation
so like everybody knew this guy and
they're like there's no way that he
would just like take off and leave his
cat behind like without feeding her and
stuff like that so it's like something
bad must have happened to him and also
they're like they thought it was unusual
that he had met with any violence
because he was a big dude they said he
was like you know really tall he was
like six foot four he was like 220
pounds there's like a big muscular guy
so wasn't defenseless right so they
thought well you know they just didn't
know what could have happened to him
because they said you know we don't
think anybody could have like
overpowered him or anything like that
but he wouldn't have just like walked up
and left a shot it may be or he were to
activate I think I think what Bruce's MO
was was that he would meet dudes on
dating apps and then he would say hey
he's into BDSM and then he would tie
them up thank you helpless it or he
would drug that man [ __ ] like I think he
did that kind of stuff so apparently
after Andrew kinsman disappeared there
was like this big Facebook group that
started like called missing rainbow
community because apparently there you
know there were a lot of like missing
people and I guess people thought that
like the police weren't looking into it
as stringently as they maybe could have
there was some like controversy I think
because they posted like this one you
know this one photo that had like these
12 people that were missing but the
problem was like some of those people
actually were found were fine one of the
people had been found dead but it was a
suicide so that you know there was like
a lot of misinformation going around and
[ __ ] like that also a lot of people in
the neighborhood were starting to
suspect that there was a serial killer
but they were thinking that the police
weren't taking them seriously because at
this point like I said they hadn't
really found any bodies so um in 2017
like summer 2017 the cops started a new
task force called project prism and this
was looking into the disappearance of
Andrew kinsmen as well as another guy
selim Essen he had disappeared in April
of 2017 from the same area like under
the same circumstances so there so the
Toronto Police are just like really they
really did seem to like pull out all the
stops like looking for all these guys
they had like the dogs out they like had
weekly like you know they're looking
through all the ravines around the
neighborhood and all this other kind of
[ __ ] now there were also a couple of
other bodies that were found around this
time there was a woman named test Richie
she was found in an alley she had been
reported missing and then for like four
days later her mom found her dead in an
alley and then the next day there was a
woman a transgender woman she had been
homeless and she was also found dead in
a ravine in August so this really like
ramped up fears that even though I don't
know I don't think there was any
evidence to link Bruce McArthur with
these two victims because these were not
his victim profile but this was
something that kind of like got the
community like all upset because they're
thinking hey there's like a serial
killer running around and you guys
aren't doing anything at all these
people are missing dude like men and
manly looking tired of men time yeah
like I said I like these victims were
made were somebody else probably but
like I said it it just seemed like there
was a lot of crime going on in this one
area at one time and like all this other
kind that's not his tastes he's not into
that yeah and that and that's what
eventually they did figure that out so
as it turned out the disappearance of
Andrew kinsman actually proved to be
kind of really important to the missing
persons investigation and also like the
linking of Bruce MacArthur to all these
crimes because on the day that Andrew
went missing apparently on his calendar
like you know for whatever he was going
to do that day he had written the name
Bruce and they also pulled the police
also pulled surveillance footage from
outside of his apartment building and it
showed him approaching what appeared to
be a 2004 red Dodge Caravan
now even though they couldn't see the
driver or the plate or anything like
that what they did was they
cross-referenced every red Dodge Caravan
from 2004 that was registered to
somebody named
Bruce and as it happened there were only
a couple and the only 2004 reg dhadkan
red Dodge Caravan that was registered to
a Bruce was registered to Bruce McArthur
so police started like putting him under
surveillance like they pulled all his
records and everything like that they
also went to the place where he had
bought the car from and found out that
he was the one that had bought the car
and they were able to confiscate the car
and when they searched Bruce MacArthur's
car they found traces of blood in it
that was identified as belonging to
Andrew kinsman now at this stage like I
said they hadn't found any of the bodies
so they start bringing cadaver dogs to
several of Bruce's you know properties
because he had more than one and he also
had like a place where one guy that he
worked for he was like renting storage
space and all this other kind of stuff
so they started having dogs looking
around now they didn't find anything at
first but as the investigation went on
they did kind of find more things now
one thing that they did find was that
when they searched his apartment they
found they went in and they cloned his
the hard drive of his computer like they
didn't take the computer they just
cloned the hard drive and when they like
looked through there they found a
partial download that was kind of like
that he had deleted the files and they
were able to like restore some of them
and they were post-mortem photos of at
least two of the victims so he had like
tried to get rid of them he was taking
pictures on the erases yeah but he's
like taking pictures of them after they
were done so what they were doing like
so like I said he was under surveillance
now they said that we're gonna put him
under surveillance um you know until we
have enough evidence but they said that
if we see him going into his apartment
with somebody then we are going to act
right away because that is probably like
bad news and something bad is gonna
happen to that person so that is exactly
what ended up happening On January 18th
2018 while the cops were outside waiting
Bruce McArthur goes into his apartment
with this other guy like a young man so
they see him go in
so the cops like busting and they find
the kid you know I'd say who's it's not
a kid but he was like you know a young
guy so he's um restrained to the bed he
had not been hurt yet um he didn't tell
them his name he was a Middle Eastern
man he said that he was it was a same
situation where he was married but had
was like living a double life he was gay
but he didn't want to tell his family
and he had actually come to Canada like
immigrated to Canada several years
earlier and he told the police that that
he had met Bruce through growler the you
know the dating app and that this was
not the first time that they had you
know met and had sex but you know so I
don't know if he was planning to kill
him this time or not but the cops busted
in and got him anyway um so apparently I
mean he did have like a black bag over
his head and tape on his mouth and stuff
like that but I don't know if that was
just like a weird sex thing they were
doing mm-hmm and because they had had
sex before and he hadn't killed them but
he might have been gonna kill him this
time but I don't know but he didn't
because the police busted in so they get
another so I would assume that uh I
would assume that if he could get it and
he was having a good time he probably
wouldn't kill him yeah I think he killed
him just if he wasn't get what he wanted
maybe that's what it was he wasn't
really having a good time you'd see try
to up and kill yeah
maybe the fight would break out he kill
him you know something like that but to
say because it does really seem like I
guess he was really active on like a
whole bunch of different dating apps
it's probably just like you know a
straight serial killer if they run
across women that were willing yeah and
then active they didn't they wouldn't
kill mid Miriam yeah it was the ones
that were kind of resistant and they
liked the resisting - yeah some well
yeah cuz they get off on they get off on
that also it was just another way yeah
you know he might have been one of his I
guess you could say one of his regulars
yeah that might have been what this
issue dudes like McDuff who were [ __ ]
vicious to women you know burn him with
cigarettes for hours and stuff like that
he had a girlfriend - yeah and all that
was going on yeah yeah that means they
want a willing
and they want an unwilling one yeah yeah
they're getting it both ways they like
it but they like both yeah so okay so at
this point after they have Bruce
MacArthur in custody and like I said the
you know they have enough to hold him
because they found like the pictures of
the you know the victims that stuff like
that like on his computer so they start
like executing he had like five
properties that they were searching they
had all the cadaver dogs and [ __ ] like
that now apparently in January the
cadaver dogs took what they called a
strong interest in I guess there were
like these big like boxes that were used
as like planters and he had installed
them like in a bunch of different places
I guess where he had been working as a
landscaper now it was kind of hard to
get into them because this was January
and a lot of them were like frozen to
the ground and [ __ ] so they had to kind
of like wrap them and like put heaters
on them and like because they had to
take the whole thing that was frozen and
they had to like take it back to the
corner so they could check and see if
there was any bodies in there now in one
of these planters they found it actually
it was two of the planters they took
twelve and in two of them they found
skeletal remains of at least three
people like they cracked these things
open and there was body parts in there
you know I mean that were frozen now the
remains were not identified at first but
this was enough to like charge McArthur
with you know three counts of murder at
this point because they presumed that he
had killed three of the men that they
were investigating from the project
Houston thing who were Majeed Cahan and
Suroosh my buddy was another guy that
had disappeared in 2015 and then there
was another guy named Dean Lissa wick
who was like a homeless man and he had
also disappeared but he had never been
reported missing because he I guess he
was a transient so like I said they're
going around like trying to you know dig
up all these planters and [ __ ] like that
they found planters from his other house
in Leeside which I guess I think that
was where he lived full time they found
the remains of three more people one of
which was Andrew kinsmen the guy that
had been in the surveillance video they
identified him through fingerprints they
found like a bunch they got a bunch of
more planners but I don't think there
were any more
there and they searched his apartment
and other kind of stuff they actually
found they also found the remains of
skin and never on tanam in another I
think that was in another planner or
like on another one of this property so
that was like another one so at this
point he was charged with eight murders
that was how many they started charging
him with it as soon as they found like
every single body and they found like
all these people's bodies and it was
pretty much all the people that they had
been investigating like it the missing
persons investigations all those people
he killed them and like he put them in
these [ __ ] planners and they were
[ __ ] so apparently it and like I said
this is pretty recent but he actually
only pleaded guilty to the eight murders
in early this year like in January of
2019 so as I said because there were all
these crimes that happened in this area
starting in 1975 when Bruce McArthur was
working in a department store like only
a couple blocks from there like started
working there in 1973 and because a lot
of the victims were stabbed strangled
tied up in a very similar fashion so
they're investigating like six hundred
cold cases hoping that they can close
them and that Bruce McArthur is
responsible for them he is not admitted
to any of them apparently although he
did plead guilty to the eight bodies
that they found yes so he's apparently
he's meeting these guys through web
dating websites and apparently his
dating profile said he's looking for
submissives because he was into BDSM so
he would meet these guys for sex
apparently like I said he didn't kill a
lot of them cuz some people were still
walking around the bars though like they
knew who he was and like he had a
reputation and [ __ ] like that but
apparently every now and then he would
get a wild hair across his ass and he
would just said like when they were tied
up or they were doing poppers or
whatever and he would just like decide
that he was gonna start stopping them
and kill them and then he was hiding
them in these [ __ ] planters and kind
of like putting them all over town like
they found him like on a bunch of
his properties and like a bunch of like
other properties that he had worked on
like that he had installed them there
grown trees out of them [ __ ]
I guess so it's like isn't that [ __ ]
up it's like yeah but they found so many
[ __ ] it's like parks I'm not they
never to check those planners well they
wouldn't have if they didn't have the
dogs I mean the dogs like found them
cadaver dogs
yeah know about that yeah so yeah so
this [ __ ] like I said it was
[ __ ] in prison now and hopefully he
never gets out yeah they said they
actually gave him life imprisonment they
said he has parole eligibility in 25
years but he'll be 91 and he has
diabetes so they don't think he's gonna
live that long so you know what I mean
and like I said it's advised lis 17 they
are still investigating whether he is
responsible for you know the murders
that happened in the 70s as well if he
is he is I'd well eight victims that's
like he might be Canada's most prolific
serial killer he's for sure the oldest
yeah because he was in his 60s when he
was caught I don't like I said that's
unusual but if the 70s he would have
been like 26 27 that wasn't his first
spree I don't think so either Elmo um
and I really don't think and I was
watching a documentary about it one of
the investigators on the case said you
know he's like it wouldn't surprise me
either way but he's like and again
Michael Arndt field the guy that wrote
that book about all those murders that
happened in Toronto and [ __ ] like that
um he's a criminologist and he was
pretty much like he's like you can't say
it because they don't have any proof but
he's like yeah I kind of think that
probably because what how weird would
that be that there was like somebody
running around back then it was like
almost the exact same thing and he and
they were targeting he was specifically
targeting people um he usually targeted
people who were immigrants people who
were not out to their families so he
knew because there was a vulnerability
there yeah like you they didn't they
wouldn't tell anybody because they were
afraid that they would be found out what
it is okay so he was targeting them
specific they were sneaking around so
that so nobody knew that they were with
him so that made a valid knock you got
to think it's like I need you know this
one nobody knows no way well no and
that's what like I think that's why he
was specifically targeting you know
those types of people particularly
I mean I think he had a thing for South
Asian men Middle Eastern men and stuff
like he seemed to like have a sexual
proclivity for that type of thing but I
also think that he was targeting
immigrants and people that were on the
down-low for that specific reason
because that gave them they were more
vulnerable right that's why well you
couldn't kill somebody who everybody
knew you were with him
yeah if everybody saw your dumb yeah you
had to kill somebody who was sneaking
around yeah and that's exactly what he
did and he killed like at least one
homeless man um you know and one of the
a couple of the ones he killed the weird
thing was though that Andrew kinsman was
really like one of the men that he
killed was really well known he had
worked in a bar in that area for like
forever and like everybody knew him he
was like you know he was a volunteer for
like a whole bunch of like charities and
stuff it's like so everybody knew who he
was so that seemed like risky and indeed
it was that guy's disappearance that
kind of like led them to Bruce MacArthur
because he had written verses named like
in his calendar or whatever okay so
before we close the show up you think
you got one more doing yeah let's talk
about and this like I said this is not a
serial killer this is just this was just
a one-off but I don't want to do this
one for a long time because this I
remember this case cuz this is [ __ ]
horrifying because I've taken Greyhound
buses before and I just could not
imagine like getting out of [ __ ]
Greyhound bus and this [ __ ] happening to
you so oh my god okay so this happened
in July of 2008 now Tim McLean who was
22 years old he was I guess he was like
a he worked at a carnival like a
traveling carnival and he had been he
was going from Alberta like he was going
back home and he was taking a Greyhound
bus like on the trans Canadian Highway
or whatever he gets on the bus and he's
in the bus and he has like headphones on
and he's fallen asleep like against the
window so then this guy it was like a
Chinese man he was like a Chinese
immigrant but in Canada for quite a long
time with his family
he's usually called Vince Li not not
Vince Li like from [ __ ] Mott got that
guy's name no no no his name was Vince
Vince from motley crew yeah
that's nothing what was it what was his
last name Vince something now I can't
think of it for some reason I was
thinking Vince Lee yeah Tommy Lee oh
it's not really a deal Vince Neil
they're okay so I was kind of close yeah
you're crossbreeding two men I don't
know if that's possible
maybe [ __ ] you know on the island of
dr. Moreau you might build a crossbreed
one I don't know if I'd want to
crossbreed those things especially not
now yeah think of the [ __ ] VD yeah I
just like just walking walking [ __ ]
viruses yeah those dudes got a rare more
virus than man at this point yeah gross
actually I heard that actually the floor
I understand those those are pretty nice
guys they're real nice guys we're just
teasing you guys they're a wild dog
whole books about how [ __ ] one's how
many STDs they I like Tommy I think
they're proud of that [ __ ] Tommy Lee
would seem to be very cool I don't know
much about Vince I don't either
Yuda throwing down a lot of women and
couchsurfing and I think he had drug
problem yeah he got real happy later
didn't because I thought oh yeah you
know I'm like a monthly round even did
kind of like a little porn movie that
Axl Rose some [ __ ] la hottie
a long time ago that's back in the 90s I
think he got I think I saw a live
performance of them that's kind of kind
of recent and yeah yeah Vince Neil is
Connor he's half ass in it when he was
singing it was mostly like he would sing
every fourth word out of the lyrics
that's all about kid stop heart yeah
whatever
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's got a breakfast
[ __ ] yeah yeah that's not good he's like
man I don't walk up so many stairs yeah
Bobby crew is a [ __ ] phenomena I
remember when I was in junior high like
the big kids you know how when you're a
junior high but back back in the old
days when you were like 13 it's like it
was like little musical clicks right so
it was like
rendering people which is me versus the
motley crue people yeah I've had I'd
have to give it to Duran Duran of course
in terms of [ __ ] musical quality yeah
well they're a lot better bass there
were a lot of bad letters they have a
lot more staying power
I think Duran was dran the [ __ ] that's
like classical music now it is then it's
like old people music [ __ ] awesome I
still listen to like wait and here you
get the first element [ __ ] like that
Miley crew I'm honest
they were an important band in the job
yeah yeah okay they were entertaining
yeah I wouldn't call him a good band in
in the you know in terms of innovation
and music not really like because they
were in in a way kind of like a copy of
kiss but with a gothic flavor to it
right especially early on with like you
know well it was their first album
almost kind of had some gothic fashion
going on for the time to love but now
they just did what worked in LA and they
did they [ __ ] ruled LA for a long
time yeah people basically were [ __ ]
trying to be motley crue yeah and it was
years and years they had like a really
long run they did what an American rock
when an American band was supposed to do
and that's get blow and chicks and you
can be very popular that's what they did
they were very successful they were very
successful yeah very successful well you
know I appreciate them for what they did
yeah for what they were and I just same
could be said for kiss-kiss was [ __ ]
they were just the masters of
merchandising and you know offer every
album maybe there were like two or three
good songs on it but yeah I put out more
albums and you know man and it was just
see what sticks they didn't care makeup
makeup and the woods show that but I
will I will
I've never saw it live but I did see
record ease kiss put on a fantastic show
well yeah you know it was like seeing
Siegfried and Roy yeah basically what it
was paid for a ticket that was you were
gonna see a fantasy
Coleman and Jenny Jenny knows she could
have tested me I've seen [ __ ] a lot
of live shows and a lot of really good
bands even set up Pink Floyd live and
I'm gonna give the crowd to the best
live performance I've ever seen was
Billy Idol on the whiplash smile tour
and the cult opened and the cult opened
for them and then the yeah the coal open
for them and that was 1987 that was the
best live show ever saw Billy Idol
knocked could knock it out of the
[ __ ] Park in those days yeah
Steve Steve Ennis and everything this
sound was [ __ ] great crowd was great
cute punk rock looking tight girls
everywhere I got into a lot of trouble
at that show great that's great that was
a [ __ ] great show in 1987 yeah
that was one of the best lot now that
was the best live show I have ever seen
Billy I don't know if I could pick one
I've seen so many oh man Skinny Puppy
was pretty good Kenny puppy was pretty
good no The Cramps yeah I got to see The
Cramps
I think it was only two years before a
Luxan terrier died yeah and he was like
in his 50s at that point put holy [ __ ]
he was climbing all over the stage it
was amazing
Glenn Danzig 1984 [ __ ] VCB 1994
[ __ ] fantastic yeah good Sawyer I saw
him at Venus de Milo and [ __ ] Venus
de Milo in Boston yeah Yeah right after
I got out of the army for the how the
gods kill yeah album tour and like I
said I was right at the front line with
some Japanese school girls that were
there [ __ ] going to college because
through all the universities were they
were dressed like some of their 1950's
Bobby soccers I should I grab dancing
foot and a jolt of satanic energy with
down my [ __ ] body I grabbed his foot
he didn't kick me that [ __ ] did not
kick me
he understood I was doing for the same
sighs he's not gonna [ __ ] Danzig was
really good he's still pretty good but
in his prime he was even better yeah I
mean everybody's
in their privacy yeah called the price
collar crime once they get old fat bald
it's like this kind of like seeing a
more macho version of [ __ ] Jim
Morrison yeah it's kinda what it was
like yeah he did have a little bit of
that error going I'm probably not as
much as Ian Astbury from the cold but
yeah same kind of vibe yeah he was good
it was good too although I must admit
when you saw the cult and Billy Idol
back to back Billy Idol blew the cult
away
yeah no cult was pretty good never been
a huge fan of the cults I have to say
they're good
I like their stuff like when they were
real like when they were still southern
Dale but once they went they went a
little too loose to metally to I don't
know they head and make that money and
that was Motley Crue talking that's yes
Motley Crue it's it's ok but it's like
I'm always kind of a minute Metallica
[ __ ] hit it really hard and that just
[ __ ] destroyed all that [ __ ] if it
even [ __ ] knocked Iron Maiden down we
yeah I mean the one-two punch of like
Metallica and then like Nirvana
understand how that yeah I remember that
happening it was almost like overnight
it was like overnight all of a sudden
that [ __ ] looks very dated although I
can go back and listen to the [ __ ]
Iron Maiden killer's album with Paul
Di'Anno [ __ ] singing and that is a 70
sound and [ __ ] hot metal album but I
can love
The Killers album that was a really good
and peace of mind with pot with what's
his name there's the singer that
replaced Paul [ __ ] come on tape it was
laughing it Bruce Dickinson versus
awesome - I could [ __ ] a hang with Bruce
yeah I'll go to a powerslave into
somewhere in time album and you know
they had a couple bad albums but I heard
there's some of their recent stuff and
it was it was pretty good yeah it's
pretty good yeah they're there
I gotta get it's hard to go back and
listen to that kind of
now that you're older it doesn't have
the same music is not as interesting as
it was well um some types of music have
more resonance when you're when you're
young younger like your formative it's
more important it's more important and
more impressive in your formative years
later on you go yeah that's pretty good
but then you know you're not really
compelled to listen to it oh you know um
alright so yeah so okay so we're on a
Greyhound bus in Canada
poor Tim McLean 22 year old guy just
minding his own business going home from
a [ __ ] fair that he'd been working at
he's sitting in the like the
second-to-last row the bus like back by
the bathrooms so they stopped at a rest
stop in like this stop in Manitoba and
this guy gets on as I said Vince Lee
that's what got started on this whole
thing yeah uh in his 40s had a shaved
head had sunglasses on now first he sits
in the front of the bus but then the
next time they stopped he moved back and
sat next to Tim McLean now Tim McLean as
I said was kind of dozing and he had
headphones on so he just kind of like
woke up and it was like hey man whatever
and then like he kind of went back to
sleep again now then all of a sudden for
no [ __ ] reason at all
Vince Lee pulls a large knife out of
somewhere and starts stabbing Tim McLean
in the chest and the neck just totally
unprovoked I'm provoked the guy was
sleeping he had headphones on can you
imagine that you're just minding your
own baby that's what free oh this freaks
me out so bad you're listening to Steely
Dan or some [ __ ] like that you're [ __ ]
chilled out you know and he just like
starts Stabbin yeah so everybody starts
screaming obviously the bus driver pulls
over all the pastor starts freaking out
and getting off then Vince Lee cuts the
guy's head off yeah in the [ __ ] bus
and then he like picks up the severed
head so all the passengers that are
outside can see it yeah so I mean like
the driver like a couple other people on
the bus had like
we tried to like they had run toward the
like tried to saved him but he was
already chatting at this point um so at
this point everybody gets off they like
locked the doors Vince tries to drive
the bus away at some point but they did
some kind of they had like an
immobilizer thing so like it wouldn't go
anywhere apparently like Vincent's like
slashing at him from behind the door was
like the knife then he goes back to
Tim's body and starts cutting other
parts of it off and like putting parts
from his pocket in there like eating
some of it Jesus this like this dude
just like normal dude gets on the bus
and like sits next and just starts doing
this kind of shape so it's crazy because
so the report that went out like when
they called the cops and everything like
that all they said was it was estabiish
but when the police get there there's
like this crazy person in the bus like
holding a hat up all the passengers are
out in the grass like on the side of the
road like throwing up and screaming and
crying and everything like that this one
guy has like trying to get like try to
give everybody crowbars we're all gonna
come on the bus and like beat the [ __ ]
out of this dude it's like all this
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] is going on so the
guy is like they're they don't really
know which they want the guy to get off
the bus it's like they're trying to like
the guys like in there like Vince is
running back and forth and like [ __ ]
like eaten parts of the body [ __ ] like
that they take all the passengers like
they put him in another thing and like
take him somewhere else they ask Vince
like what your deal and he's reportedly
said to the cops I have to stay on the
bus forever that's what he said and I
was like yeah I guess so
so he was on there for like several
hours and then he tried to get out of
the bus like by like breaking out of the
window he's insane and then they said
they tasered him yeah and handcuffed him
and put him in the car yeah now they
found some of the body parts of things
in the bus and they found the Tim's ear
his nose and tongue in Vince's pockets
they never did find his eyes or parts of
his heart and they presumed that Vince
ate them yeah
this [ __ ] crazy yes okay now
the craziest thing about this is that
this guy like when they found they
it's so sad man because like all the
people that were on the bus like all
their [ __ ] luggage and [ __ ] was on the
bus and obviously they didn't want to go
back on the bus to get their [ __ ] so
like the granite when the Greyhound
representatives like came they had to
take him take them all to like a
department store buy them all new [ __ ]
like why a mall and they closed and
everything because they're like because
of the trauma and also they're kind of
crap and I think it ended up like one of
the investigators that was like the
first on the scene I think he killed
himself later on because of like that's
a typo yeah cuz it [ __ ] his head up
cuz he was just like damn it was the
most horrible thing he'd ever seen
which you know which it would be so that
when they investigate this guy they find
out this guy he'd been born in China in
1968 he had a Bachelor of Science degree
in computers and he had actually worked
as a software engineer in Beijing for a
while but he had lived in Canada since
2001 and had been a Canadian citizen
since 2002 so why hire a Chinese guy
Chinese guy okay um yeah now apparently
he didn't have like any kind of record
or anything he had spent like a brief
time in a psychiatric hospital like a
couple of years or something like that
but I guess they thought he was alright
and they let him back out again got
tired of those white people I don't know
man he had a wife her name was Anna um
he had a job he had some kind of
psychotic break or he did it had to be
something like or he took some kind of
bizarre ass [ __ ] drug what year was
this 2006 - or 2008 could he have taken
some of that flock flock house that I
was gonna say yeah this sounds like some
flock oh yeah yeah maybe he took his
flock I was [ __ ] real cheap [ __ ]
drug that is like an emulator supposed
to be like an emulator for another drug
I don't know yeah I think it might be an
emulator for acid or something I don't
know LSD and it just [ __ ] you up bad
quality stuff there's a lot of [ __ ]
weird Chinese emulators yeah some of
them emulate weed some emulate LSD some
emulate heroin and they're chemically
cotton not quite the same and your body
just can't [ __ ] process them and they
cause you to go insane yeah because the
weird thing about it is that when they
start investing these guys background
like I said he was a totally normal dude
like he had a wife he'd had several jobs
like I said he'd worked as a software
engineer but when he moved to Canada
like you know he could speak English but
not
well I think Florida might be an
emulator for [ __ ] and feta means
maybe he took some kind of a [ __ ] in
you know I mean a fake and feta mean
yeah and it just [ __ ] him up yeah cuz
the Chinese guy might be aware of
something like that
yeah could be you know yeah yeah they
come from China yeah I don't know just
that's just me talking this is straight
you know it doesn't sound like normal
psychology and doesn't sound like
somebody just yeah it was crazy it
sounds like drugs
yeah because any history of this type of
thing same thing that dude here in
Florida that other guy's face
yeah that's what this reminded me all
right because so like I said they look
into this dude's background like I said
he had been he had been a software
engineer but when he moved to Canada
like he could speak some English but
apparently like not as well as like some
jobs needed so he'd been worried like he
worked at Walmart he worked at fast-food
restaurants he worked like his forklift
operator he'd but he had jobs he had a
wife and [ __ ] like that he seemed
totally normal like all his employers
said you know yeah sometimes he had a
little bit of trouble communicating and
stuff because his English wasn't very
good but they said that he didn't have
any anger issues he was totally fine
however about a month before the murder
he got fired from Walmart because I
guess he got like into an argument with
some of the other employees but I guess
he had asked for like some time off
because he was gonna go like for a job
interview or something like that now
when they started like asking witnesses
and [ __ ] they said that now he's been
acting a little weird before he even got
on the bus because they said the night
before um apparently he had gotten like
all his luggage he had like three pieces
of luggage and he'd gotten off this one
bus in this stop in Manitoba which is
like where he got on the bus like where
Tim MacLean was now he had slept on a
bench at the bus station like with his
luggage and apparently one witness saw
him on this bench at 3 a.m. and that he
was sitting on this bench like bolt
upright with his eyes like wide open and
he was just like staring like into space
and they thought that was really weird
so they thought it was so after it
happened like they reported it they also
said that the next morning like before
he
on the bus that he stopped this 15 year
old boy and sold him a brand new laptop
computer for $60 just as drugs yes so
this is like something like that and
like all the other passengers on the bus
that like witnessed it
they said the creepiest thing was that
when he took the knife out and started
stabbing the guy they said he wasn't mad
he didn't look psychotic you know he
looked totally calmed they said he
looked like a robot like he was just
like staring and just like stabbing like
he got it didn't he got his hands on one
of those cheap Chinese drugs like
[ __ ] bath salts I guess something
like that really weird so he goes on
trial in 2009
well it's insanity defense sanity yeah
um he said that God's voice told him
that Tim McLean was evil and that he had
to execute him he said God had told him
that um so a bunch of psychiatrists like
examined him and they agreed that he
should get an insanity defense [ __ ]
yeah yeah so he was actually sent to a
mental health center now the crazy thing
though is that so he was in this
psychiatric center for a long time and
they said he didn't have like no
problems at all he responded completely
fine and normally to all psychiatric
treatment and slowly they started giving
him more and more privileges like they'd
let him run like walk around the yard
and then they'd let him walk
unsupervised and then they would let him
piss so as of now he's out they let him
out like after a few years because they
didn't think he was a threat anymore so
I don't know if they determined that he
just had a psychotic break and it was
unlikely to happen again know if you if
you're sick and afterwards it could
happen you're always gonna be dazed
that's it yeah it kind of but now he has
changed his name so I don't know what
his name is now um but a parent I'm in I
think they're still like keep a track of
him and [ __ ] like where he's at but he
has apparently changed his name and has
started a new life somewhere one of my
mom's relatives you know she's got like
nine sisters and one of those sisters
somehow had some kind of weird cousin
who I just heard about it through the
family he was kind of like that he
killed his son
yeah sacrificed him to God
but he was but he was a nut he was in a
mental institution yeah they let him out
on it like a day pass to come visit his
family and he's playing with his kid
this is somewhere at Massachusetts it's
like one of my mom's cousins I think
that's what it was cousin not really
related to me you know this is yeah but
he went to go visit his parents and his
son was there to visit his son was like
five you know they had a lake and a damn
rowboat
you know he goes takes his son out on
the rowboat and he's young we're talking
about a guy who's like you know 35 and
he comes back in the house and he's
happy and [ __ ] and woke up attack an
hour went by the where's your son cuz oh
he's out in the boat so what's he doing
out of the boat it was all I sacrificed
him to God and he was out there the
little boy was out in the boat it
stabbed [ __ ] how he could tell you
about it I forgot about it that's crazy
yeah yeah told me that stabbed him right
in the heart with a [ __ ] knife and
then that was it they locked him up in
the mental asylum for the rest of his
life that's crazy yeah and he hadn't
anything like that before but he had it
this is the kind of show that scares ya
he had come boy he had some kind of
schizophrenia yeah it was like
schizophrenia he would he was hearing
god yeah well apparently that's what
happened yeah that maybe it's like this
guy like I said you said that I was like
oh yeah you know nothing it's like he
was completely normal you know jobs he
had a wife he had everything and then
just all of a sudden he just decided
he's gonna get on the bus and sit next
to this guy and just stab him and cut
his head off and eat parts of him just
as some kind of weird schizophrenia yeah
it was just like some totally did yeah I
guess so
and like I said he was in the mental
institution for a while but they let him
out in 2000 2017 I believe they let him
out and he's changed his name I don't
know where he's living now but like I
said I hope they're probably under some
kind of medication but I would hope so
what if he forgets to take it one day no
no no but what I'm telling you about
that story that was like mid 60's yeah
that happens like a long time ago have
to ask her about that
yeah find out what happened that did
that's pretty scary she Protestant know
any more than I do anymore though that
was like
when that [ __ ] went down she was like a
little girl yeah you know well not
really little girl teenager in a way
this is almost like kind of scarier than
serial killers because the serial killer
it's like usually they start early and
like they have a thing where they do but
it's like you know it's it's scary to
think that it's just like a totally
normal person they could just be totally
normal until they're like forty five
years old then all of sudden they flip
out and cut people's heads out it's like
you had somebody's head off just for no
[ __ ] reason sacrifice their son to
God
yeah that's why you know that's like
creepy because you know the human brain
is very complex and it's like who knows
what kind of [ __ ] you like snap in there
like all of a sudden one day I moved
that Abraham and Isaac action yeah
that's like because I mean I've been
like researching this [ __ ] all day but
now that I'm like talking about it out
loud I'm like oh come I snap in any
minute that's what I mean we'll see it
could be I'll just snap the [ __ ] up one
of these days oh snap like that and it's
like you know anybody do you think what
do you think about them what do we think
about them well course you know people
snap right I snap snap snap them damn
straps on that underwear I wear you did
yeah that's right yeah understand some
funny feet a man sometimes looks better
in a bra I saw the pictures Dennis I saw
the pictures of you and that bra I mean
look like [ __ ]
I mean there's like all belly and hair
like fur yeah yeah it's weird gray it's
never a guy you'd want to see in a bra
no I don't want to see you [ __ ] above
a girl bra it's always somebody there
yes you don't know it's always kind of
like you know like those nude beaches
what was that what was what you hear
that okay what was it a cat or something
yeah yeah but you know like those nude
beaches where they like [ __ ] the top
of all this ghostly [ __ ] [ __ ] and
scare me back there well I thought the
captain's trying to come and kill me man
are they outside there's one cat inside
okay
okay Worthen she's always making but no
I said it's like those nude beaches man
it's like people get excited when
they're young it's like I'm gonna go to
the nude beach it's never anybody you
want to see naked just so I'm just
telling you right now it's always like
really old yeah men look like yeah real
out of shape leathery little leathery
looking women blowing some fat boy yeah
it's not like you're a man it's not like
it's not like a porn movie yeah not like
a bunch of hot like [ __ ] tight asses
or it's not gonna happen that way it's
like old stanky some things about it you
know anything about a little Spanish
community it's so easy you don't want
ones that are showing it don't want to
see it it's true all right so we
probably gone on way long enough about
all these Canadian crimes hopefully you
guys enjoyed it you're rambling like we
usually do I don't know what all that
ghostly noise wasn't a chicken but we
gotta stop the recording and see what
that is because there might be some
haunted [ __ ] going I can't ask him to
come back in it might spit probably is
actually because one of the cats is she
like ones into the door and like bangs
oh I thought I thought this famteam is
coming to get me I could guess you were
gonna cuz you snaps oh snap they already
knew here they come buckets snap just
like a thing of celery I'm drunk man
shut the [ __ ] 172 hope you guys enjoyed
it and remember if you like the show
like share subscribe share with all your
friends on all your social media yada
yada cuz it really does help us a lot
give us a like subscribe that's right
patreon [ __ ] go to patreon go to our
blog to the point now there's somebody
if you give us a dollar it works it
helps yeah every little bit so now you
know you get early access to the
episodes like if you're $20 nope you get
like shirts you get all kind of free
[ __ ] you had all kind of fun things so
that'll do it for episode 172 we will
see you next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]